Hätte ich selbst nicht gedacht. Hätte mir das einer vor einem Jahr erzählt. Hätte gesagt, ihr habt sie nicht mehr alle, aber ich gehe tatsächlich regelmäßig rennen und Fahrradfahren.
Fragt mich nicht, was mich da geritten hat, aber irgendwie war es mir mal wieder danach.
Und ich habe mir gesagt, ey, du gehst jetzt alle zwei Tage rennen und seit ungefähr drei Monaten mache ich das auch.
Zwischenzeitlich nicht mehr exakt alle zwei Tage, sondern unterbrochen noch zwischendurch mit Fahrradfahren.
Und natürlich habe ich mir auch wieder ein Fahrrad gekauft. Kein billiges Fahrrad, sondern natürlich was ordentliches.
Und ich hatte wieder mal massive Glück, denn nach einem Monat mit dem neuen Fahrrad hat mich direkt jemand mitten auf dem Fahrradweg umgefahren mit dem Auto.
Ganz toll. Richtig schön BAM wie Bruce Lee von der Seite weggerammt.
Und zum Glück ist mir nicht so viel passiert. Ich hatte ein bisschen Abschürfungen am Arm und am Bein, aber das Fahrrad ist im Arsch.
Und nun Anwalt, Versicherung. Alter Leute, das ist so bürokratischer Overload wieder.
Meine Güte, das geht mir echt extrem auf den Keks.
Und übrigens, wer sich für meine Zeit interessiert und so weiter, also wie schnell ich irgendwie fünf Kilometer, zehn Kilometer hier ran bin,
der kann mal auf Twitter schauen. Da poste ich öfters mal ein paar Updates.
Und natürlich nebenbei den anderen Posts, wie kacke die deutsche Bahn ist, wenn es mal wieder ist.
Wobei, was? Wenn? Wenn ist mal. Das ist eigentlich fast jedes Mal.
Also so mal als Spoiler. Ich blende euch mal meine aktuelle Bestzeit über zehn Kilometer ein.
Ist frisch von gestern. Und ich habe überlegt, ob ich da nicht mal etwas längeres Video dazu machen sollte.
Ich habe ja auch schon ein Video dazu gemacht, wie ich 17 Kilo abgenommen habe.
Jetzt ist es noch ein bisschen weniger geworden.
Also das heißt, wenn ihr wollt, dass ich mich mal für ein Video als krasser Fitness-Influencer betätige, dann sagt mir mal Bescheid.
Da kann ich euch das alles im Detail erklären.
Und kommen wir jetzt einfach mal zum Eigentlichen, was ich euch erzählen wollte.
Und ich glaube, ich habe das letztens bei mir auf Twitch im Stream schon erzählt.
Aber das ist so bescheuert. Ich denke, das kann man ruhig zweimal erzählen.
Ich war vor Jahren öfters mal in der Commerzbank-Kantine in Frankfurt.
Oh, Leak! Oh nein!
Aber ich glaube, da war nicht nur ich, da waren täglich sehr viele Leute und wahrscheinlich auch der ein oder andere von euch eventuell.
Ihr könnt mir ja mal Bescheid sagen, ob ihr das noch kennt.
Das war diese ganz alte Commerzbank-Kantine.
Also falls da mal jemand gewesen ist.
Diese mit zwei Stöcken.
So Richtung, ja, was ist da hinten?
So Richtung Englisch Theater in Frankfurt ist das gewesen.
So eine zweistöckige Kantine.
Die gibt es auch, glaube ich, nicht mehr.
Also ich war in der Ecke auch von der ganzen Weile nicht mehr.
Also falls ihr da auch mal waren, würd mich interessieren.
Lasst mich mal wissen.
Und ich bin da halt ab und zu auch mal zum Mittagessen mit ein paar Leuten hin.
Die Kantine war jetzt nicht super krass.
Aber war recht günstig und das nur.
So, fertig.
Da bin ich.
Wer das restliche Video von mir guckt, wenn ihr auf YouTube geht.
Ich dachte mir, ein bisschen Viewtime schadet auf jeden Fall nicht.
Was gilt hier als HighIQ?
Nur Leute mit PrimeSub.
Ja, ja.
Erklärst du im Chat, wie man richtig kackt oder was?
Aber das ist eigentlich bei HighIQ nicht notwendig.
Reicht ArchLinux für HighIQ?
Also, safe wäre tatsächlich PrimeSub plus ArchLinux.
Da kannst du eigentlich nichts mehr verkehrt machen.
Aber ArchLinux allein, es geht in die richtige Richtung.
Ich konnte endlich mal ein Pflaster abmachen vom Finger.
Man sieht ziemlich einen tiefen Schnitt noch.
Also die Linie von dem Schnitt sieht man noch im Finger.
Aber es ist, so wie es aussieht für mich, alles halbwegs gerade zusammengewachsen.
Also, ich glaube, das kann man so lassen.
Es hat gar nicht so wehgetan, wie es ausgesehen hat.
Also, ich habe es ja letztens erzählt im Stream.
Ich wollte so einen kleinen Sensor aufmachen.
Und habe da aus meinem iFixit Kit dieses Teil hier rausgeholt.
Das da.
Das ist kein Messer.
Das ist eigentlich nur ein Stück Metall.
Wo man schön so in Gehäuse reinbohren kann von der Seite.
Ohne die Gehäuse komplett zu zerstören.
Und die aufhebeln.
Also, das ist nicht wirklich darauf geschliffen vorne scharf zu sein.
Aber ich bin halt mit richtig schwaches abgerutscht.
Und habe mir in Mittelfinger geschnitten auf der anderen Hand vorne.
Also so ungefähr ein Zentimeter vielleicht.
Gut und gerne ein Zentimeter.
Und ich glaube, das war halt echt bis zum Knochen durch.
Das war echt tief.
Wenn man an der Seite dran gezogen hat, war es schon ganz schön tief.
Und hat auch geblutet wie Sau.
Und ich dachte mir so, ja komm, was war es?
Einfach sauber machen, desinfizieren und feste Pflaster drum wickeln.
Und hoffen, dass es wieder alles gerade zusammenwächst.
Und anscheinend ist auch alles ein Zentimeter lang.
Nicht ein Zentimeter tief.
Weil ein Zentimeter ist ja der Finger kaum dick.
Oh, ich habe oben reingeschnitten.
Da bist du ja direkt am Knochen quasi dran.
Ja, das war nicht so nice.
Zurzeit ist Verletzungschamp angesagt, so wie es aussieht.
Ich gehe nicht zum Arzt wegen sowas.
Zurzeit ist aber echt Verletzungschamp angesagt.
Erst Unfall mit dem Fahrrad, jetzt den Finger geschnitten.
Und was auch immer.
Da muss ich vielleicht mal aufpassen.
Wer weiß, was sonst noch kommt.
Das ist das Einzige, was mich der Arzt gefragt hat, als ich zu ihm gegangen bin.
Also nach dem Fahrradunfall.
Also ein Zentimeter tief bedeutet gleich Finger ab.
Das Einzige, was er mich gefragt hat, er war eh total lustlos und hatte keinen Bock.
Und das Einzige, was er mich gefragt hat, ist, ob ich geimpft bin.
Also Tetanusimpfung und Zeug.
Das war so, der hatte erst überhaupt keinen Bock.
Also der Arzt hatte wirklich überhaupt keinen Bock, wo ich reingegangen bin.
Und da habe ich ihm gesagt gleich am Anfang, also ich bin jetzt eigentlich nur hier,
falls ich das für die Versicherung brauche, dass man das dann alles festgehalten hat.
Und da ist er auf einmal hellhörig geworden und hat sich Mühe gegeben.
Weil es ja sein kann, dass ich von ihm danach nochmal einen ordentlichen Zettel brauche,
wo das alles draufsteht.
Man kostet zwar extra.
Hat er auch gleich gesagt, hat er auch gleich gesagt.
Ja, aber das kostet dann extra.
Ja, das ist egal, wenn es soweit ist.
Aber das habe ich schon total oft gemerkt, dass die zum größten Teil mega lustlos sind.
Deswegen gehe ich auch mittlerweile ganz gerne, wenn es nicht so aussieht,
als kostet es gleich 50 Millionen und bezahle das selbst.
Weil da kann man sich die Arztpraxis nahezu aussuchen, auch mit Terminen.
Und das ist deutlich angenehmer.
Und die geben sich auch immer mehr Mühe als bei der gesetzlichen Karte.
Ich habe jetzt noch ein Jahr Zeit, mich privat versichern zu lassen.
Und ich glaube, ich mache das auch.
Also nicht zum Geld sparen oder so.
Es mag am Anfang ein bisschen weniger sein, später mehr.
Aber es ist einfach besser.
An der Kohle soll es letztendlich nicht liegen.
An der Kohle soll es nicht scheitern.
Und, was sagst du?
Fazit?
Also alle Leute, mit denen ich bisher geredet habe, die privat versichert sind,
haben gesagt, okay, das ist schon sinnvoll.
Aber, also die finden das gut.
Aber sie haben teilweise den Eindruck, also das haben nicht alle gesagt,
dass sie es gut finden, haben alle gesagt.
Aber was auch viele gesagt haben, ist, dass sie teilweise echt,
wie soll man sagen, fast schon overbehandelt werden.
Irgendeiner hat erzählt, Probleme am Bein gehabt, gleich erstmal 20 mal röntgen
und dann erstmal noch gucken, könnte auch was am Kopf sein, MRT gemacht.
Dabei war eigentlich gar nichts und dem ging es auch nicht schlecht.
Und, was auch einer gemeint hat, ist, wenn man sich privat versichert,
sollte man nach Möglichkeit, wobei ich das für, naja,
bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob das gute Advice ist.
Ich sag es einfach mal.
Da könnt ihr im HiIQ-Chat sagen, was ihr davon haltet.
Ich bin mir da unschlüssig, ob das so sinnvoll ist.
Der hat gesagt, wenn man sich privat versichern lässt,
ist es sinnvoll, auch im gleichen Zuge eine Berufsunfähigkeitsversicherung abzuschließen,
weil gerade in dem Moment, wo du halt berufsunfähig wirst
und es dir dann nicht mehr leisten könntest, ist es das, wo du es wirklich brauchst.
Klingt erstmal logisch, auf der anderen Seite muss man sagen,
das ist saumäßig teuer.
Letztendlich sind Versicherungen immer so eine Wette auf die Zukunft,
dass die halt dann nicht so gut, aber auf der anderen Seite
ja, wie gesagt, es ist enorm viel Geld,
was eine Berufsunfähigkeitsversicherung kostet
und ist halt die Frage, ob man da drauf,
ja, weißte, ich bin da nicht so sicher.
Ja gut, deswegen sagt man ja auch, man sollte noch vor 40 oder bis 40,
sagen wir mal, anfangen, das zu machen.
Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt, du hast recht.
Wie gesagt, das Ganze ist immer so ein bisschen eine Wette,
ja, das ist schwierig, schwierig zu sagen.
Man kann auch super viel Geld reinbuttern
und im Endeffekt dann hat man tausende Euro,
zehntausende, wenn nicht hunderttausende Euro bezahlt
für irgendwas, was du halt nie verwendest.
Es ist bei Versicherungen so,
das ist immer so ein bisschen kleine Wette auf die Zukunft.
Theoretisch kannst du auch in Stonks investieren.
Naja, aber Privatversichern werde ich machen, bevor ich 40 bin.
Ich bin jetzt schon das letzte Jahr über immer wieder am gucken.
Das Einzige, was wahrscheinlich Kacke sein wird, ist,
jetzt nicht mehr, aber ich hatte ne ganze Weile,
naja, ne ganze Weile,
ein paar Jahre lang ein bisschen zu hohen Blutdruck.
Nicht super zu hoch, wirklich minimals zu hoch,
aber das ist halt ärztlich bekannt,
da kann ich nicht irgendwie sagen,
ja, war mir nicht bekannt so, ja.
Und du musst es ja auch ausfüllen am Anfang
und das kostet, egal ob das jetzt noch so ist oder nicht,
und egal wie lang das war,
da wollen sie bestimmt super krass Aufpreis haben,
30 Prozent oder was auch immer,
kann ich mir vorstellen.
Dann mal gucken, ob sich das Ganze noch lohnt.
Zumindest werde ich mir mehrere Angebote angucken.
Wie alt ich bin?
Ich bin jetzt gerade noch nicht so lang 39.
Also kann man ja nicht sehen,
es kommt darauf an, was es ist.
Und gerade da brauchst du wahrscheinlich dann gute Versorgung.
Arbeitsunfähigkeit heißt ja nicht,
dass du unbedingt für dein restliches Leben
arbeitsunfähig sein musst, zwangsläufig, ja.
Und selbst dann liegst du nicht im Bett,
irgendwie im Koma und kriegst nichts mehr mit,
also selbst dann bräuchte es das eigentlich
und dann hast du es vielleicht nicht mehr.
Aber, ja, wie gesagt,
das ist immer schwer zu prädikten alles.
Ich werde mir das angucken.
Traue ich mich da drauf zu klicken?
Ja, okay.
Also die Dinger gestern waren lustiger.
CheesyPro, danke für den Sub.
Das ist der erste High IQ Sub heute.
So ist das.
Direkt IQ Increase für alle, die da sind.
Also natürlich nur Leute, die schon da waren um 20.30 Uhr.
Das geht nicht zurückwirkend.
Der Knochen ist legit,
Leute, wenn ihr oben auf euren Fingern guckt,
da ist Haut und direkt drunter Knochen.
Ich rede nicht unten vom Finger, oben vom Finger.
Bisschen, nee, hab ich nicht.
Ich höre mich manchmal,
manchmal ein bisschen so an,
wenn ich gerade einen Stream angemacht habe
und mich noch nicht so eingeschwätzt habe.
Da hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Das ist auch so ein Ding,
wo ich bei privater Krankenversicherung
echt keinen Bock drauf habe,
ist den ganzen Papierkram immer, wenn was war,
hinschicken und dann warten,
Also das mit Karte ist schon nice.
Ich verstehe gar nicht,
warum sich da nicht auch so was wie eine Karte etabliert hat,
mit der du abrechnen kannst.
Gibt's? Nö, wo soll's das geben?
Ja, per App einreichen.
Ja, du musst dich halt immer noch selbst drum kümmern.
Du musst es im Zweifelsfall einscannen
oder da hinschicken oder dann per App.
Aber, ja, okay.
Ja, muss man mal gucken.
So was wäre auf jeden Fall ganz sinnig.
Naja.
Hast du schon die Million zusammen?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich hab glaub ich noch nie alles zusammen gerechnet.
Ich mein, offiziell gehört mir das Haus gar nicht.
Also, dann eher nicht.
Mit dem Haus vielleicht, aber
dann auch eher nicht.
Aber ohne Haus garantiert nicht.
Ja.
Naja, ich hoffe auch,
dass es mir noch eine Weile nicht gehört.
Ja, Leute, ich hab heute das Video hochgeladen
und hab gedacht, ich schalt mal auf YouTube
die Videopremiere rein.
Das hat YouTube wirklich komplett durcheinander gebracht.
In den Analytics hab ich das angeklickt.
Du hast bei Analytics,
vielleicht kennt das ja der eine oder andere von euch,
du hast bei Analytics immer so eine Anzeige
Bestes Video und mehr als Durchschnitt und sowas.
Das war Bestes Video und grüne Pfeile
für geiles Video,
aber es hatte gleichzeitig
die wenigsten Views von allen Videos.
Und zwar 95% weniger.
Also es wurde quasi die komplette Premiere,
die zehn Minuten Laufzeit von der Premiere
nicht mit reingezählt
und es hat YouTube komplett verwirrt.
Komplett durcheinander gemacht.
Ja, YouTube ist komisch drauf teilweise,
was die Anzeige hier angeht.
Das liegt höchstwahrscheinlich an
an Return YouTube Dislikes.
Das spackt manchmal ein bisschen rum.
Hallo Leute, hier ist der Max und er...
Also ich hab oftmals das Problem mit Premiere,
dass ich es im Hintergrund laufen lasse
und auf einmal kommt dieser
ultra eklig laute
Pre... wie heißt das so?
So Intro Sound.
Diese zwei Minuten.
Dann denkst du immer
Alter, was ist jetzt los?
Oder schreckst du dich übertrieben?
Nee, bin ich nicht.
Bei dir stehen 48...
Es ist einfach nur broken as fuck.
Wobei 48k hat es auch garantiert definitiv nicht.
Das letzte Video hatte 48k,
das aktuelle nicht.
Es ist übelst kaputt.
Was auch immer, ist egal.
Ist das was für dich?
IKEA Heck für Wandleuchte.
Oh ja, das ist immer nice.
Was ist das?
Das ist Heise Plus, das können wir uns gar nicht angucken.
IKEA Heck für Wandleuchte
obgren...
Moment, okay.
Schwedisch.
Was?
Nur Finnisch ist noch krasser.
Das ist komplett
Elbensprache einfach nur.
Tauscht man die eingebaute CPU
der IKEA Wandleuchte
obgren...
Moment.
Achtung.
Obegrenzade.
Was?
Okay, alles klar.
Obegrenzade.
Gegen einen ESP
lässt sich die LED Matrix
frei bespielen und sogar als Uhr nutzen.
Och ja, das ist eigentlich
ganz cool.
Aber ich brauche es nicht.
Leute, das ist so ein typisches Ding.
Ich gucke mir das an und denke mir, oh cool, das würde ich gerne basteln.
Und wenn ich mir dann überlege im nächsten Schritt
Ja, wo würdest du es denn hinstellen?
Was würdest du darauf anzeigen und machen?
Dann fällt mir nichts ein, wofür es sinnvoll wäre.
Weil ich habe meine zwei
Dashboard-Tablets im Flur hängen
und alles, was das Ding anzeigen könnte,
könnte ich einfach so einem Dashboard-Tablet anzeigen lassen.
Aber ist es eine gute Idee?
Da gibt es doch garantiert
auf YouTube ein Video zu.
ESP.
Siehste? Gibt es doch hier schon.
ESP Home.
Eine Arduino-Library für das IKEA
Frequenz-LED-Panel.
ESP Home
IKEA LED-Matrix.
Ja, aber
habt ihr irgendeine schlaue Idee, was man
darauf anzeigen lassen könnte? Also mir fällt jetzt
erstmal nichts ein.
Keine Ahnung.
Was kannst du alles von mir über Twitch
herausfinden?
Da musst du wahrscheinlich eher die Modgis fragen.
Die blicken da besser durch.
Wie die Content-Moderator-Sachen
auf Twitch funktionieren.
Also ich weiß, dass ich sehen kann
von dir, was du für Nachrichten geschrieben hast.
Oder ansonsten?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich gucke ja da meistens auch nicht rein.
Ich gucke immer nur mal kurz rein, wenn irgendwelche
Leute komisches Zeug spammen.
Beim Chainlaw bin ich es nicht anders gewöhnt, aber
in der Regel gibt es ja manchmal Leute, die
joinen den Channel und spammen gleich
komisches Zeug. Da gucke ich immer nach,
waren die schon mal, haben die schon mal komisches Zeug gespammt
und wenn ja, dann werden sie gebannt.
Aber ansonsten gucke ich da eigentlich
so gut wie nicht rein.
Das macht auch keinen Sinn.
Ich muss mal kurz Package-Update machen, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Archlinux braucht immer
Package-Update, weil
Bleeding Edge.
Leute, heute
auf der Arbeit habe ich
eine VM angelegt, wieder mal,
bei Google,
in der Konfig, wie wir sie brauchen würden,
dass das alles funktioniert,
wie wir uns das vorstellen.
Und das würde über 5000 Euro im Monat kosten.
Für eine VM.
Und
ne, nicht 100k.
Und der Witz ist halt,
wenn man zu OVH oder
Hetzner oder sonst was geht und sich irgendeine
Bare-Metal-Kiste kauft,
bezahlt man maximal
700 Euro im Monat dafür und hat
was viel, viel besseres.
Also, es ist halt schon
ein bisschen doof, dass die bei uns auf der Arbeit
so auf Google Cloud festgelegt sind.
Aber gut, ich verstehe das
als Versicherung musst du gucken,
wo die Daten gespeichert werden und
die haben auch irgendwelche
Agreements mit den, irgendwelche
Sus-K-Agreeges mit den Anbietern.
Ich versteh's ja, aber
es ist halt schon ein bisschen doof und
dann auch teuer.
Ja, naja.
Das hauptsächlich teure ist die Disk.
Also die VM kostet
ein Drittel und die Disk kostet zwei Drittel.
Guck mal,
die Frage ist die gleiche,
warum keine Kiste von Hetzner,
warum keine Kiste von OVH,
warum nicht bei AWS, warum dieses
und jenes, weil sie sich für Google Cloud
entschieden haben, irgendwann mal vor meiner Zeit
wahrscheinlich auch extra Verträge mit Google Cloud
haben, irgendwelche Abmachungen,
irgendwelche business-strongs-Dinger.
Da kannst du nicht einfach woanders was bestellen.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr was ich mir
auch schon überlegt habe? Chat?
Ohne Scheiß, wisst ihr was ich mir
überlegt habe? Wir hosten das.
Ne, das hab ich mir nicht überlegt, das beim Sebaru hosten.
Aber was ich mir auch schon überlegt habe ist,
ob ich nicht einfach
mit
irgendjemand zusammen
so eine Kiste in der Cloud aufbauen soll,
bei Hetzner oder so
und das dann versuchen
an die zu verkaufen
als Service.
Da werde ich keinen Bock drauf haben,
aber ich mein, probieren kann man's
ja mal.
Die können mir die 5K auch geben,
hab ich auch keine Probleme mit, anstatt
Google zu geben.
Bei Keck Cloud, das ist gut.
Warum nicht bei Keck W Cloud?
Ne.
So, Package
Update ist durch, jawoll.
Next, Package Update.
Gibt nix.
Ja, außer das Twimochi.
Das regt mich ja immer noch auf, dass Twimochi
nicht mehr gepflegt wird, dass Elon
den Open-Source-Twitter-Emoji-Font
eingestellt hat. Das ist so richtig
kacke
für mich, ja.
OpenAI-Keynote gestern gesehen? Nein, hab ich noch nicht gesehen.
Hab ich in meiner Playlist
für heute Abend auf dem Handy.
Guck ich mir an, wenn ich ins Bett geh, mach ich an
und vielleicht penn ich dabei ein, kann sein.
Hab ich mir vorhin gespeichert.
Gab's irgendwas Spannendes?
Chat-GPT 5 oder
die machen Keynotes, ja.
Whisper ist raus. Heißt, wir haben jetzt
bald noch bessere
Transkript-Erkennung
fürs Archiv.
4 Turbo.
Aha.
Ne, das gucken wir nicht.
Was können wir uns denn auf YouTube jetzt angucken?
Moment, ist das nicht
der Tempel-OS-Dude?
Das ist doch der Tempel-OS-Kerl, ja.
Jetzt haben wir gestern
die Video-Empfehlung
heute wieder, Mann.
Komm in die Gruppe
Bustens Stongs?
Auf was wurde der denn kritisiert?
Ich guck das
so gut wie nie, aber die Videos,
die ich geguckt hab, die waren eigentlich ganz gut.
Was wird denn da kritisiert
wieder? Okay, echt?
100 Millionen saved.
No more AWS.
Und das ist mir
zu anstrengend
zu gucken heute Abend.
YouTube made Ad-Blockers better.
Unabhängig davon,
was er in dem Video erzählt,
der prinzipiellen Aussage
würde ich zustimmen,
dass YouTube
durch ihre neuen
Ad-Blocker-Umgehungsmechanismen
Ad-Blocker besser gemacht hat,
weil die Ad-Blocker sich
anpassen mussten an die YouTube-Umgehungsmechanismen.
Also unterm Strich
würde ich tatsächlich sagen, dass die
Ad-Blocker dadurch potenziell
besser geworden sind und besser werden.
keckweb.cloud übrigens noch zu haben.
Bin mir gar nicht sicher,
ob ich das nicht sogar mal gekauft habe
und jetzt wieder expired ist.
Ich hatte total viele sinnlose,
ich hatte auch Kappa-Lul und sowas,
richtig dämliche Domains,
die ich mir mal, ich hatte mal so eine,
die letzten paar Jahre über hatte ich mal immer so
den Tick, mir jede
Domain zu kaufen, wo ich dachte, der Name
ist richtig, ist irgendwie
total bescheuert, weil die waren
auch meistens billig, diese Domains. Die waren
billig, da hast du dann irgendwie gesagt,
okay, bezahlst 4 Dollar oder so
für die Domain, da hab ich gedacht, ja, easy.
Aber ich hatte irgendwann mal zwischenzeitlich
16 Domains oder sowas.
16! Naja.
Und jetzt hab ich noch
glaub 5. Und eine
davon liegt tatsächlich noch bei
Nitrado.
Ich kann mich gar nicht mehr erinnern
über welche Umwege die jemals
zu Nitrado gekommen sind.
Und ich wollte die umziehen
zu Cloudflare
schon ganz lange, aber
das geht nicht.
Okay, wer ist HiRQ? Wer weiß?
Heute ist HiRQ-Stream, ich muss das jetzt
ab und zu mal abfragen.
Wer weiß, warum ich meine Domain nicht zu Cloudflare
umziehen konnte?
Hat jemand eine Idee?
Hast du schon über den Cloudflare-Ausfall gesprochen?
Nee, gab's da was?
Personalausweis?
Nee, nee, das ist es nicht.
Gab's da, gab's
einen Ausfall? GMX United
Internet hatte gestern einen Ausfall.
Das hab ich mitbekommen.
Cloudflare?
Nameserver nicht änderbar? Nein.
Umzugssperre für Domains? Nein.
Okay, ihr wisst,
ihr wisst das nicht. Wir wählen die nötigen
Prime-Subs anscheinend.
Nee, das wissen die wenigsten und man hält das auch
gar nicht für möglich, aber
DE-Domains gehen nicht
bei Cloudflare.
Cloudflare unterstützt so gut wie alle Domains,
bloß keine DE-Domains. Ja,
richtig, Chat, so sieht's aus. Cloudflare
kann keine DE-Domains.
Man glaubt es nicht.
Ja, so als eines der bekanntesten
Dinger, die es da so gibt,
aber Cloudflare kann keine DE-Domains.
Man glaubt es nicht, ist aber
so. Moment, kurz Issues
checken. Keine neuen Issues, alles gut.
Die 23 Offenen
ignorieren wir einfach mal.
Was bei Cloudflare ist, ein ganzes RZ
überwiegend Monitoring. Ja, gut so.
Monitoring,
outdated, overrated, debated.
Die haben keinen Vertrag mit dem Denik, ja.
Ich kenn den ehemaligen Denik-Chef,
der soll das mal regeln.
Den müsste ich mal anrufen, sag hier, mach mal.
Sag mal
dem neuen Denik-Chef, mach
Vertrag mit Cloudflare. Ich will meine
Max-FPS-Domain umziehen.
Macht er bestimmt. Oder auch
nicht. So.
Richtig, das ist
das Diff, das Diff
der Issues ist null.
Das wäre eigentlich mal eine gute
Metrik für irgendwas.
Man hat 300 Issues,
die Leute haben schon keinen Bock mehr, machen einfach
keine neue mehr auf und man erfasst
nur den Issue-Diff.
Und dann ist es immer null und dann können alle
sagen, wir sind grün, was Issues
anbelangt und dann freuen sie sich und
können weitermachen. Den Cloudflare-DNS
benutze ich auch für die
meisten Domains.
Ja, das ist natürlich blöd.
Manchmal
beißt es einen ein bisschen, wenn man
zu krasse High-Security-Sachen
hat. Es gibt ja so automatische
Türen, wo du dann rein musst,
gewogen wirst und dann geht es quasi
zu so Schleusentüren.
Und
wenn du sowas hast und es nicht geht,
ist es halt kacke, wenn gerade einer drinsteht und es
ausfällt.
Da kriegst du dann echt ein bisschen Platzangst.
Nun ja, ich habe keine Ahnung,
wie das genau funktioniert.
Ich habe mich damit nie beschäftigt.
Das fällt nicht aus. Die Dinger sind super stabil.
Also damals
habe ich nicht 150 Kilo gewogen. Damals
habe ich wahrscheinlich, aber auch,
als ich mal in sowas rein musste, habe ich aber bestimmt auch schon
100 plus gewogen.
Und da hatte ich noch fette Server dabei.
Also 150
war es nicht, aber die halten schon ein bisschen was aus.
Ja.
Möglich, möglich.
Das brauchst du gar nicht dafür.
Warum brauchst du das?
Achso!
Weil du DNS-Authentifizierung machst
mit Let's Encrypt.
Da muss das Ding aber nirgendwo drauf
zeigen.
Du brauchst keine
A-Records. TXT-Records
für Let's Encrypt DNS-Authentifizierung reichen aus.
Aber du kannst es auch lokal
auflösen lassen.
Es macht es weder besser noch schlechter.
Ne, also dort im Errechnungszentrum,
wo ich war, waren die Schleusen einfach zum
Eingehen und da war vermutlich eine Kamera
drin. Die haben dann geguckt, ob das alles
passt und haben dann
freigegeben.
Schaust du irgendwelche Sportarten bzw. E-Sport?
Also ich
schaue, also E-Sport schaue ich seit Jahren.
In letzter Zeit allerdings tatsächlich
ein bisschen weniger.
Ich habe jahrelang beispielsweise
super gerne StarCraft geguckt, bis Blizzard
dann irgendwann komplett keinen Bock mehr drauf hatte.
Fand ich super zum Zugucken.
Ich habe nie großartig selbst gespielt,
also fand ich das super zum Zugucken.
Ansonsten, ich habe auch mal
eine Zeit lang wirklich viel CS geguckt.
Ich war sogar auf ein paar Major-Turnieren
vor Ort. Belegt euch mal,
hier, Offline-Events, Cack Wait,
hat mir das angeguckt.
Aber in letzter Zeit
ist es doch recht wenig,
was ich an E-Sport gucke.
Ja, und so klassische Sportarten gucke ich
eigentlich auch nicht.
Ich gucke,
ich gucke ab und zu mal ein bisschen,
also so die ganz großen Sachen wie
Fußball oder jetzt, was gerade
richtig gehypt war, weil in Frankfurt
irgendwas war. Gucken ja manche
Leute auch Football und sowas.
Das ist in Deutschland
ziemlich Nische, aber irgendwie
in den letzten Jahren hat es ein bisschen Aufruhren gehabt.
Also weder Fußball
noch sonst was. Das Einzige, was ich ab
und zu mal gucke, ist,
wenn irgendwelche Radrennen
sind, gucke ich manchmal rein.
Das habe ich auch schon
gemacht, bevor ich mir jetzt ein Fahrrad
gekauft habe.
Das gucke ich manchmal ganz gerne an,
weil es entspannt ist. Da kann man sich mal 1-2 Stunden
davor setzen und
sich quasi die Ende von irgendeiner Etappe angucken.
Muss nicht unbedingt gleich Tour de France sein,
irgendwas kann man sich angucken.
Sehr entspannt.
Aber ansonsten gucke ich
eigentlich so gut wie nix.
Ich war einmal in meinem Leben
auf einem Fußballspiel und das war
bei der Eintracht. Und das
fand ich so
langweilig
und
ich habe mich die ganze Zeit gefragt
dort, was
mache ich da eigentlich?
Und seitdem habe ich nicht
einmal irgendwas mehr
mit Fußball mir angeguckt.
Habt ihr vom Dienstleister
der SIT
gehört?
Die Angreifer haben deren RZ mit
Ransomware befallen, sind 72 Kommunen
betroffen, über 20.000 User
ohne Anbindung
zu den Kommunen. Nee, habe ich nicht gelesen.
Aber
bei Behörden-IT
wundert mich nix.
Solche Schleusen.
Eine Personen-Vereinzelungskabine.
Das ist auch
nicht ganz, aber sowas
in der... Also das war rund,
wo ich rein musste. Das ist ja eckig.
Weil das für die Funktion
wahrscheinlich nicht viel Unterschied macht.
Und es war auch nur eine,
aber rund. Aber
in die Richtung geht das, ja.
Nur, dass man gewogen
wurde.
Was ist da drin? Dark Zone, danke für den Sub.
Nee, Eishockey.
Eishockey habe ich tatsächlich auch mal am Rande
gesehen. Da waren wir mal
in der Eissporthalle in
Frankfurt und mussten dann
runter
vom Eis,
weil irgendwie Training oder so
angefangen hat. Und da haben wir
ein bisschen geguckt, was da so ab... Das war auch
mega langweilig, Alter.
Gut, ich meine, das war kein
richtiges Spiel und nix, aber
ich weiß nicht. Ich finde das super
langweilig, die meisten Sportarten
zum Gucken. Und konnte...
Ach, die machen auch sowas. Okay.
Da muss ich ja echt sagen,
ich lobe ja selten
irgendwelche Behörden
und sonst was. Aber ich
habe in Hanau
vor nicht allzu langer Zeit mir einen neuen
Personalausweis abholen müssen.
Und die haben das... Ich wundere
selbst, dass ich das jetzt sage, aber
die haben das
wirklich gut gemacht.
Du kannst dich online anmelden für einen Termin,
dann gehst du da hin,
dann kriegst du eine Nummer,
dann gehst du da hin zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo
es dir gesagt wird. Wartest zehn
Minuten, wenn es hochkommt, dann kommt die Nummer
an, du gehst rein, die haben alles
da, von Fingerabdruck-
Maschinen bis...
Ja, ich weiß, könnte man jetzt kein Alu
vermuten, aber es ist halt trotzdem praktisch, weil alles
vor Ort ist. Für Fotos, für Fingerabdrücke,
für alles, was man braucht.
Und dann bist du dann in einer halben Stunde dort
wieder raus und kriegst eine Nachricht,
wenn du abholen kannst. Wenn du abholen
kannst, kannst du direkt vorne
dich melden
und kriegst den ausgehändigt.
Also das ist mega nice gemacht.
Also das ging
komplett problemlos. Hey, ich dachte
schon, fuck, das muss ich mir noch einen Personalausweis
holen, ultra nervig und abfuck und alles.
Und
es ging einfach richtig gut.
Da hab ich richtig gequadet.
Was sind deine
größten Kritikpunkte,
beziehungsweise Verbesserungsvorschläge
bei Kubernetes?
Boah, da müsste ich jetzt echt mal drüber nachdenken.
Also
für vieles, was ich für
Kritikpunkte hab oder was ich halt als nervig
empfinde, ist nicht mal so sehr die Schuld
von Kubernetes. Das ist beispielsweise
dieses super wilde Ökosystem
um Kubernetes drum herum,
wo es laufend was Neues
gibt, irgendwas verschwindet,
irgendwas super essential ist, dann wieder
nicht und
50 Sachen
für den gleichen Kram und
zigtausend neue Abkürzungen am Tag,
die kreiert werden. Also das Ökosystem ist
super weird champ, da mitzuhalten.
Aber an Kubernetes selbst?
Ja, es gibt so ein paar nervige
Sachen, wobei sich da einige sogar schon
gefixt haben.
Ja, zum Beispiel kriegst du manchmal
die Meldung, dass dein
kubectl-apply zu
groß ist und so solche Geschichten.
Und da gibt es ein paar Workarounds für.
Und dass du manchmal manche Sachen nicht
einspielen kannst, das ist nervig.
Und ja, manche Innereien
sind auch ein bisschen doppelt gemoppelt
und bisschen
weird, so
Endpoint, Endpoint Slice,
Endpoint
für irgendwas. Braucht man aber
meistens gar nicht.
Da müsste ich mir echt mal Gedanken drüber
machen. Es hängt ja auch viel
gar nicht so sehr an Kubernetes,
sondern an dem, der die Plattform betreibt
dafür, wie gut das funktioniert.
Also zum Beispiel kannst du
zwar in Kubernetes einen Loadbalancer-Typ
definieren, aber das hängt
vom Provider ab, der dein Kubernetes hostet,
was dann passiert.
Das ist nicht built-in.
Ist Hanau nicht das übelste
Shithole? Hanau ist, wie viele
Städte, in manchen Ecken das
übelste Shithole und in manchen
Ecken ganz okay.
Also es gibt eine Ecke in
Hanau, die ist wirklich ihr übelstes
Shithole und das ist zwar nicht
vergleichbar mit Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof. Moment.
Hanau Maps. Ich zeige euch mal was.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das noch finde.
Aber
schauen wir uns das mal an.
Hanau, so.
Nein, nein, nein.
So, das muss irgendwo
hier.
Genau, hier hinten ist auch
so eine, hier hinten
ist auch so eine Assi-Ecke.
Hier,
hier hinten.
Und da gab es mal, ich habe
keine Ahnung, ob ich das noch finde.
Da gab es mal
ein Haus,
wo könnte das gewesen sein?
Hier oder so?
Da gab es, sieht gerade nicht so schlimm aus.
Das ist es aber nicht.
Aber die Ecke stimmt halbwegs.
Da gab es mal ein Haus,
das hatte
eingezäunte Balkons.
Das war ganz, ganz
weird. Da bist du dran vorbeigelaufen
und die im Erdgeschoss
haben sich mit Draht und so den Balkon
eingezäunt.
Also der Balkon war halt so niedrig im Erdgeschoss,
dass die Leute theoretisch reinklettern konnten.
Und die haben wohl so schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht,
dass sie mit Draht ihren Balkon
eingezäunt haben.
Und das sah auch
richtig Assi drum herum aus.
Ich weiß nicht.
Hier hinten, irgendwo
hier hinten ist das aber, glaube ich.
Vielleicht
irgendwo bei was
Kleiner. Ja, ja, ja,
sieht schon so ein bisschen.
Aber das ist nicht hier.
Ah, die Ecke,
die Ecke stimmt. Vielleicht gibt es
das auch gar nicht mehr.
Vielleicht sieht es dir viel zu gut aus hier.
Vielleicht gibt es das auch nicht mehr.
Das war zumindest auch
so ein richtig Assi Ding.
Aber ansonsten,
ohne Mist, Hanau ist vollkommen okay.
Freiheitsplatz ist auch so ein Ding, wo du
abends dir teilweise
die Gestalten angucken kannst.
Aber das ist alles nicht vergleichbar mit Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof.
Es ist schon
echt in Ordnung. Und gerade wenn
du hier beispielsweise
ein bisschen
raus ins Grüne und so was,
da ist das schon ganz gut.
Hier oben, das hier ist halt auch viel Assi-Zeug.
Ja, sehe ich
genauso. Ja,
ich finde es auch total beschissen, dass man,
also richtig beschissen, dass man Fingerabdrücke abgeben muss
für den Personalausweis. Ich sehe das auch
nicht ein, aber du kannst auch nichts dagegen machen.
Also gäbe es Möglichkeiten, da drum herum
zu kommen, hätte ich
das gemacht. Ja, das ist
nicht schlecht.
Sehe ich auch so.
Und nicht diesen Blödsinn
von Monat, Tag, Jahr.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, das beste
Date ist immer noch
direkt Unix-Timestamp.
Da musst du dir keine Gedanken um
Zeitzone oder so Müll machen.
Also wenn du es lokal betreibst,
musst du sowas wie Metal LB verwenden.
Das ist direkt neben dem
Bahnhof beim Bus.
Gibt es nicht mehr.
Du meinst, das Haus war eingezäunt. Du, du kennst das?
Du kommst auch aus der Ecke, oder wie?
Ich war da auch
ewig nicht mehr. Ja, okay.
Das stimmt schon. Am Bahnhof
in Hanau, hier ist es auch
so eine richtige Assi-Ecke.
Da oben, wo das
Arbeitsamt ist. Hier ist doch
irgendwo das Arbeitsamt.
Hier ist das
Arbeitsamt. So, die
Ecke hier ist auch ein bisschen
fragwürdig
teilweise.
Das sieht hier gar nicht so wild aus
eigentlich.
Aber hier hast du schon so ein paar Spezialisten.
Also ihr seht schon,
das ist nicht mit Frankfurt zu vergleichen.
Hier ist der Friedhof.
Kann sein, dass das hier hinten irgendwo war.
Ey, aber
Hanau geht schon echt klar.
Niemals wird Wayland-Support
available sein.
So, lass mal gucken. Haben wir irgendwas auf YouTube zu gucken?
Was haben wir denn hier?
Lasst euch nicht alles...
Ah, das ist der Kerl, der durch den Wald läuft
bei den Videos.
Das war ja gar nicht so übel, was wir das letzte Mal geguckt haben.
Fand ich halt schlecht.
In diesem Video teile ich meine persönliche
Erfahrung als Softwareentwickler.
Naja, gut.
Dann verteilen.
Und wie ich
mich von einem belastenden
Arbeitsumfeld
zu einer erfolgreichen
Selbst... Oh, vielleicht ist das auch eher so ein Comedy-
Gruppe-Video.
Also da hab ich jetzt aber eigentlich nicht den...
Mein erster Auftrag.
Der narzisstische Geschäfts...
Ich kann das Wort nicht aussprechen.
Geschäftsführer. Albtraum in der
Arbeitswelt.
Die Aktion, die alles veränderte.
Okay. Das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an.
Bin ich mal
gespannt, was das ist.
Ob das...
Ich mein, die Aktion, die alles
verändert, die ist so typischer. Könnte man auch
in den Titel schreiben.
Guck, ob das stimmt.
Ja, alle
sind es am jammern.
Kennt ihr...
Mir fällt gerade eine Sache ein.
Kennt ihr das?
Das ist auch eine Sache, die mich
in der Arbeitswelt übelst...
Vielleicht ist das auch so ein IT-Ding.
Übelst nervt. Also Beispiel.
Beispiel, ja.
Wir machen es jetzt mal abstrakt.
Sonst wird es zu kompliziert. Mal angenommen,
ihr seid in irgendeinem Projekt drinnen
und ihr seid die ganze Zeit schon
am darauf
hinweisen, dass
irgendwas
so nicht funktionieren wird,
wie man sich das gedacht hat.
Ihr sagt das Wochen,
ihr sagt das ein paar Wochen lang,
es interessiert keinen großartig und
irgendwann entweder fällt
auf, dass ihr die ganze Zeit recht
hattet oder
irgendjemand hört doch mal auf euch,
dass das nicht so
gut ist, auch wenn das vielleicht was unangenehmes
ist und
dann kommt in
zwei Wochen oder so
dann irgendwann
dein Chef zu dir und
fragt dich, sag mal, wie sieht es denn
mit diesem und diesem Thema aus?
Damit läuft es ja angeblich gar nicht gut.
Ich habe das von meinem Chef gehört
und wie sieht es denn da aus?
Und dann denke ich mir so, Moment.
Du fragst den
Falschen. Das ist das Thema,
das ist
bei dir gelandet um Dreiecken wahrscheinlich,
weil ich das angesprochen habe,
dass es Kacke ist. Das ist nicht so, dass
es Kacke ist, weil wir das
Kacke gemacht haben, sondern
von mir kommt das, dass das Mist ist.
Wisst ihr,
was ich meine? Das ist total weird.
Es gibt so,
mir fällt jetzt kein konkretes Beispiel ein
und dann, wenn daraus irgendwelche
Maßnahmen abgeleitet
werden, wirst du dann
gefragt so, ja und, wann geht es denn
da weiter? Dabei bist du
derjenige, der das eigentlich haben will.
Also, du wirst dann
genervt mit deinen eigenen
Sachen, die gemacht
werden. Das ist teilweise
total weird und das liegt dann daran,
weil das über zu viele Ecken
geht. Das ist mir auch schon aufgefallen. Das geht
über zu viele Ecken. Du sagst das,
irgendjemand vom Projekt checkt das
dann, der gibt das weiter,
das kommt dann irgendwann zum Abteilungsleiter
oder sonst wie noch weiter höher, dann geht es
wieder drei Gruppen runter, dann kommt das irgendwann
zu deinem Chef von deiner Gruppe
und dann hörst du es wieder und dann
sind dann ganz andere Sachen auf einmal dabei,
die du so gar nicht gesagt hast.
Ganz weird ist das
teilweise.
Und dann kommt da so, ja, also der Abteilungsleiter
hätte da gerne einen Status
und sowas oder der
Projektmanager hat einen Status
und ich sage, Alter, ich sage seit
drei Wochen, dass das Müll ist.
Was für einen Status soll ich geben?
Es ist immer noch Müll.
Warum werde ich jetzt nach
meinen eigenen Sachen gefragt,
die ich die ganze Zeit anmecke?
Geschäftsführer
will Status, hat es vorher nicht interessiert.
Was wollen die Status haben?
Als hat sich das auf einmal jetzt geändert.
Das ist aber immer, wenn es über
zu viele Ecken geht.
Das sind immer so Sachen, das nervt mich
im Keck-Wait-Business-Umfeld.
Jetzt gucken wir uns das gerade an.
Und jetzt, ich darf nicht so viel stoppen,
sonst wird das ja heute nicht fertig.
Und zwar gab es in den Kommentaren zum letzten Video,
wo es darum ging, welche Fehler professionelle
Softwareentwickler heute bereuen.
Und zwar hat AniaPlays geschrieben, mein größter Fehler
entstand durch eine schlechte Arbeitsumgebung.
Mein ehemaliger Abteilungsleiter hatte
stark narzisstische Persönlichkeiten.
Da habe ich
echt Glück beim neuen Laden.
Sowohl mein Chef als auch der Abteilungsleiter,
der vorher witzigerweise mein Chef war.
Also, das sind
mit
die besten Führungskräfte
so auch, wie soll man das sagen,
wo du auch merkst, die haben mal eine gewisse
Führungskräfte-Ausbildung genossen
und wurden da nicht
einfach so reingeschmissen.
Also das sind, zumindest vom
Kenntnisstand her, wie man solche Sachen macht
mit den besten Führungskräften, die ich bisher hatte.
Und jetzt nicht schleimen,
in der Hoffnung so,
niemand guckt meinen Stream von da, das juckt keinen.
Die wissen gar nicht, doch theoretisch
könnten sie es aus der Bewerbung wissen, aber wurscht.
Bestimmt keiner am Start.
Du merkst, dass dort, wo ich jetzt
gelandet bin, dass nicht random
Leute in diese Position geschmissen werden,
sondern, dass sie tatsächlich
ein Führungskräfte-Förderungsprogramm
haben, ich weiß nicht, wie das genau
heißt, wo du schon bevor du
überhaupt
das mal werden kannst,
ja, Führungskräfte-Seminare
und Kurse belegen kannst,
dass du dann, wenn es denn dann mal
soweit ist oder wenn du es denn dann wirklich
machen willst, auch halbwegs ready bist.
Das merkst du den Leuten an.
Das ist beispielsweise, so ein ganz krasser Vergleich
zu meinem letzten Laden ist,
sobald es irgendwelche Konflikte gibt,
normalerweise,
also ganz krass mit meinem
vorletzten Chef oder so vom letzten Laden,
normalerweise sollte man davon ausgehen,
der Teamleiter, der sollte,
wenn es Konflikte gibt,
nicht
noch Benzin ins Feuer gießen,
sondern nach
Möglichkeit versuchen,
die Leute wieder halbwegs normal miteinander reden.
Und
ich hatte mal einen Chef,
auch bei dem letzten Laden, wo ich gewesen bin,
das war das genaue Gegenteil,
der hat dann noch mitgemacht
und dann ist das Ganze noch mehr eskaliert.
Also,
das ist genau das Gegenteil von dem,
was du eigentlich machen solltest.
Also,
so ein fiktives
Beispiel.
Irgendeiner geht
zum Chef und sagt,
der Max macht immer nur Scheiße.
Normalerweise würde man dann
sagen, okay, wir hängen das erstmal nicht an die große Glocke,
aber
der Chef, den ich damals hatte, der hätte
das anders gehandhabt. Also, jemand
kommt zu dem und sagt, der Max macht immer nur Scheiße.
Dann würde mein Chef
sagen, ah, warte mal, ich ruf den kurz an,
hätte mich dann rüber zitiert ins Büro
und hätte mich gefragt, Max,
sag mal, warum machst du immer nur Scheiße?
Das wäre so seine
Deeskalationsstrategie gewesen
damals.
Du stehst dann,
das hatte ich bei dem öfters mal, du stehst
ohne jegliche Information bei dem
im Büro und sollst
zu irgendwas Dingern Stellung nehmen
und irgendwann habe ich
dann auch mir das mal überlegt,
okay, also, macht ja keinen Sinn
und
ich habe dann immer gesagt, also,
wenn mal wieder sowas gekommen ist,
ich weiß jetzt nicht, was ihr meint, also,
ich kann mir da nichts drunter
vorstellen, was ihr mir
sagen wollt,
erklärt doch erstmal,
eigentlich hätte ich,
du kannst in so einer Situation
eigentlich das komplette Gespräch
direkt vergessen,
ich habe es versucht, dann immer noch ein bisschen, weil
es war oftmals wegen den
sinnlosesten Sachen
und
wegen den Sinnlosen, ich habe es dann versucht,
ein bisschen so abzuschwächen, indem ich gesagt habe,
erklärt doch erstmal, was ist eigentlich das Problem,
normalerweise hättest du eigentlich
sagen müssen, ja, meldet euch mal wieder, wenn ihr
euch beruhigt habt,
das war so einer, der hat da noch
immer mitgemacht,
also, anstatt zu versuchen,
die Leute mal ein bisschen wieder
auf den Boden der Tatsachen
zurückzubekommen und das ist sowas,
das würde es, also, aktuell
mit dem Abteilungsleiter,
den wir da haben,
habe ich deutlich besseren Eindruck, da würde
sowas nicht passieren, doch, geht's?
Also,
zumindest ein Job in der IT,
das muss nicht zwangsläufig jetzt in der IT
sein, das kann durchaus sein, dass es überall so
Leute, also, es gibt überall so
Leute, schon was von CyberArk
gehört, ja,
grausam,
was ich davon bisher gesehen habe.
Es erfüllt
seinen Zweck, also, was man jetzt aber so, CyberArk
hat ja tausend verschiedene Produkte,
aber die machen zum Beispiel,
ihr müsst euch vorstellen, CyberArk
hat ein Produkt, ihr werdet euch jetzt am Kopf
greifen, warum man sowas überhaupt verwenden sollte,
die haben ein Produkt,
um legal
SSH-Verbindungen zu
man-in-the-middlen
und da denkt man sich doch, warum um alles in der Welt
sollte man sowas verwenden, aber doch,
es gibt Leute, die verwenden das,
die man-in-the-middlen alle SSH-Verbindungen
von ihren Mitarbeitern
mit dem Tool dann,
das gibt es. Dadurch geht
natürlich auch viele Sachen nicht mehr richtig,
aber, ja, ich kenne manche Produkte
von denen, ich bin da nicht sonderlich begeistert
von, so.
Jetzt müssen wir aber echt mal, sonst wird das mit dem Video
heute nichts.
Ganz ehrlich,
dass es Ruhe in die
Sache bringen, das habe ich auch versucht,
das
klappt aber nicht, wenn du einen
Chef hast, der daran nicht interessiert ist.
Ich denke, mittlerweile wäre
echt das Beste gewesen in der Situation damals,
aber ich meine, ich habe mir da nie großartig,
tja, war da meistens
nicht so richtig vorbereitet damals drauf.
Das Beste in der Situation
wäre jetzt
so rückblickend gewesen,
ich hätte gesagt, okay, wir können ja dann drüber
reden, wenn sich alle beruhigt haben.
Es hat keinen Sinn, wenn du zwei
Leute hast, die sich übelst aufregen,
der eine sich dann auch gerade voll reinsteigert
und das dein Chef ist, das irgendwie
an Ort und Stelle klären zu wollen.
Das kann,
das funktioniert unterm Strich nicht.
Naja, lass uns das mal klären,
wenn sich alle beruhigt haben.
Es kann natürlich sein, dass er noch mehr ausflippt,
aber dann hast du ja echt allen Grund
zu sagen, nee, jetzt nicht.
Was will er machen? Will er sich dann
beschweren irgendwo?
Mit dem Motto, Mitarbeiter möchte nicht mit mir reden,
wenn ich ihn anschreie. Das klappt ja nicht.
Und man muss sagen, angeschrien hat er die Leute
eigentlich nicht, aber er hat sich immer übelst aufgeregt.
Ja, es gibt schon komische
Leute da, deswegen hatte ich
darauf auch keinen Bock mehr.
Glücklicherweise hat sich das dann
auch von alleine
erledigt, an dieser Position.
Das haben auch andere mitbekommen, dass der,
glaube ich, nicht gerade der Beste
dafür gewesen ist.
Aber ich war ja noch schon in einem anderen
Team danach.
Naja, okay.
Und als ich diesen Kommentar gelesen
habe, ist mir eingefallen, ich habe da ja
auch noch eine Story, die
unglaublich krass ist und die ihr noch gar
nicht kennt. Ich erzähle euch
heute von meinem allerersten
Projekt als Freiberufler.
Und dieses Projekt war so unglaublich
und da sind solche Dinge vorgefallen,
dass jeder Tag am Ende
mehr oder weniger war wie in so einer
total übertriebenen Version von Stromberg.
Ich erzähle euch aber nicht nur,
was damals vorgefallen ist, sondern auch,
was das aus mir gemacht hat. Warum das mit
dazu beigetragen hat, dass ich der
geworden bin, der ich heute bin. Und vor allen Dingen,
wie ich vor ungefähr vier
Wochen das Ganze dann
für mich noch zu einem guten Ende
drehen konnte. Also, auf geht's
in die Vergangenheit. Nach dem Intro geht's
los. Viel Spaß.
Vor meiner Karriere als Freelancer
war ich im Studium, damals im
Bachelor-Master-Studium, angestellter
bei einem kleinen Unternehmen hier im Sauerland.
Und parallel war ich noch
Expert-Student-Partner bei Microsoft.
Gleichzeitig war ich mittlerweile mit
meinem Studium fertig. Das heißt, ich hatte in meinem
Master-Studium eine Schraube für eins geschrieben.
Das Einzige, was ich noch machen musste,
war meine Masterarbeit. Und als ich damals
in meinem damaligen Job im Büro saß
und am Programmieren war, bekam ich eine E-Mail
auf meinem privaten Account von
einem Geschäftsführer von einem Unternehmen
ungefähr zwei Autostunden von meinem
Wohnort entfernt. Und der war auf
mich aufmerksam geworden durch eine
Konferenz von Microsoft und ein Kollege hatte
mich weiterempfohlen. Und zwar ging es darum,
dass er in seinem Unternehmen, was Software
entwickelte damals... Mal was ganz was anderes
zu dem Video. Ich finde, der hat eine angenehme
Beleuchtung in den Videos. Komplett
random jetzt, aber fällt mir
gerade auf. ... schon eine
neue Software entwickeln wollte auf einer
neuen Plattform auf Microsoft-Technologie.
Also auf jeden Fall angenehmer als
das, wo er durch den Wald gelaufen
ist. Nee, finde ich angenehm
Ein Teil dieser Software,
eine Logistik-Software, neu entwickelt werden
auf .NET-Basis mit
ASPM-VC damals. Also du
merkst an der Art und Weise, wie er erzählt,
dass er, ja,
Freiberufler,
Dienstleister ist. Die müssen ihre
Sachen ja default
gut verkaufen können.
Und er hat jemanden gesucht,
der einmal seinen Mitarbeitern diese
Technologien beibringt und auf der anderen
Seite dann die ersten Schritte in diesem Projekt
anleitet, also dieses Team anleitet
und damit dann quasi dieses Produkt
fertigstellt. Das ganze Projekt sollte
zwei Jahre lang gehen und
ich wurde dann gebeten, einfach in der
nächsten Woche mal vorbeizukommen. Dann könnten wir in seinem Büro
alle Details klären. Ich wollte
damals eigentlich nie Freiberufler
werden. Ich wollte nie selbstständig werden,
sondern ich hatte eigentlich vor, eine Karriere in der
Uni zu starten. Ich wollte promovieren und wollte dann
in der Forschung mich um
Architektur und Softwarequalität kümmern.
Aber das war natürlich eine Chance. Ich bin
angefahren zu diesem Meeting, hab mir das von
dem Geschäftsführer alles erklären lassen, hab mir schon mal Teile
vom Team zeigen lassen, so ein bisschen die Version
zeigen lassen, was er vorhatte und das war
damit... Chat! Ich frag mich,
wie gut er seine Software dokumentiert.
Ist ganz klar, das ist so
ein krasser Freelancer, der macht
keine Fehler und muss dementsprechend auch nichts
dokumentieren. Und Tests brauchst du
logischerweise auch nicht, weil wenn's First Try
funktioniert und alles
durchdacht ist, was willst du da testen?
Für mich mit Mitte 20 schon ziemlich beeindruckend.
Das war ein großes Unternehmen, die haben
namhafte Kunden gehabt und das Projekt,
denen das beizubringen, dieses Projekt zu leiten,
fand ich schon unglaublich spannend.
Aber, er hat gesagt, ich möchte das Ganze nur
machen, wenn sie bis dahin
Freiberufler sind und dann Freiberufler
sind. Ok, verständlich. Ich weiß noch, ich bin nach Hause
gefahren und ich war total
gestrilled. Ich war total gehypt
und hab meiner damaligen
Verboten, heute Ehefrau,
sofort erzählt, was da alles vor ist und wie cool
das wird und was man da alles machen könnte.
Und ihr müsst natürlich überlegen, ich war da noch
kein Freiberufler. Ich hatte zwar einen Gewerbe angemeldet
für meine Microsoft-Konferenz und die Sachen, die ich so
nebenbei gemacht habe, aber ich
wollte, wie gesagt, nicht Freiberufler werden.
Und gerade in dieser Lebenssituation,
meine Frau war hochschwanger, es waren noch
zwei oder drei Monate, bis mein Sohn geboren werden sollte
und ein halbes Jahr, bis wir heiraten
wollten, das war alles andere als
so diese Situation, wo man normalerweise
seine Freiberufler-Tätigkeit anfängt.
Weil es ist ja mit Risiken verbunden, mit finanziellen
Risiken und was nicht alles. Und daher
war das eine ganz schön schwierige Entscheidung.
Und ich weiß noch, ich habe damals mit meiner Verlobten abends
zusammengesessen im Wohnzimmer und sie hat
gesagt, weißt du was, David, mach das. Das ist
eine super Gelegenheit. Wer weiß, wann sich
so eine Gelegenheit nochmal gibt.
Am nächsten Tag bin ich dann direkt
zum Steuerberater. Im Steuerberater
meine Freiberuflichkeit angemeldet,
bin danach zur Bank,
hab mir einen Kredit organisiert, weil
ich musste jetzt dann immer zwei Stunden dorthin fahren
und damals mein Studiauto war
ein Golf 3, glaube ich, der schon
Moment, warum ist die erste Amtshandlung
sich ein Auto zu kaufen, wenn man kein Geld hat?
Okay,
macht
vielleicht besseren Eindruck, keine Ahnung.
Und ich hab mir dann einen Kredit bei der Bank geholt und bin
direkt am nächsten Tag dann nach Nürnberg
gefahren und hab mir meinen ersten Firmenwagen
gekauft, weil der Sohn kurz
vor der Geburt war,
hab ich ja ein Ford Mondeo gekauft,
ein super geniales Auto, aber gut, anderes Thema.
Als Freiberufler ist ein Auto
recht... Ja, aber er hat doch gesagt, er hat ein Golf.
Verstehe ich nicht. Okay, aber...
Das war der Start in meine Selbstständigkeit.
Und dann, in der Folgewoche,
dann ging auch schon das Projekt los.
Der Start war schon mal schwierig,
weil die Kollegen, die ich jetzt dort
hatte, die ich einarbeiten sollte, davon waren
drei Azubis. Drei Azubis?
Wie groß war das Team? Fünf Leute,
drei Azubis?
Das geht schon mal gut los.
Bürokaufleute
mit IT-Informatik. Was ja nicht schlimm ist.
Das waren also
vorwiegend welche, die Bürokaufleute
werden wollten, die aber
jetzt eben Softwareentwicklung machen sollten.
Das war schon irgendwie ein bisschen komisch, aber
es war mir egal. Das war mein erstes Team.
Auf der anderen Seite, es gibt ja
durchaus Leute, die haben es da auch übelst
drauf. Vielleicht stellen die fest,
Bürokaufmann war dann doch nicht
das Richtige für sie. Ich bin übrigens auch
so jemand, der festgestellt hat, dass Bürokaufmann nicht
das Richtige ist. Ihr wisst, ich hab auch mal
so eine Keck-Business-Ausbildung gemacht.
Aber
je nachdem, wie groß das Team war.
Also wenn der Azubi-Anteil größer 50%
ist, ist das auf jeden Fall
merkwürdig
meistens. Das war dort, wo ich
meine Ausbildung gemacht hab, beim Provider
oftmals auch so. Die hatten glaube ich von
Mitarbeiter oder so, waren 50
plus Azubis.
Und das waren dann einfach nur
billige Arbeitskräfte. Auf der
anderen Seite, für mich war es gut.
Das war so eine typische, du kannst
alles lernen, wenn du willst, aber
du kannst auch, also so eine Ausbildung
kannst alles lernen, wenn du willst,
weil du kannst alles machen, wenn du willst,
weil es keinen wirklich interessiert,
ob du jetzt Azubi bist
oder nicht. Und auf der anderen Seite
hättest du auch drei Jahre abchillen können und am Ende
nichts gelernt.
Wie man Softwareentwicklung macht, alles von Grund auf.
Und wir haben dann über mehrere Wochen,
ich glaube am Ende waren es drei Monate, haben wir uns die ganzen
Technologien angeschaut. Hinterher auch Workshops gemacht,
Übungen gemacht, haben uns C-Sharp angeguckt,
haben uns SQL Server angeguckt, haben uns Entity Framework
angeguckt, ASP, HTML, CSS,
diese ganzen Sachen haben wir angeguckt.
Das war natürlich für die eine extrem
spannende Reise, aber natürlich auch eine große
Herausforderung, wenn man da nicht viel Programmierkenntnisse hat
und wenn man da vorher noch nicht richtig viel
gemacht hat. Nichtsdestotrotz
waren zwei von den Kollegen wirklich richtig, richtig
gut, die haben das dann auch überlebt.
Und zusätzlich noch ein älterer
Kollege, der vorher schon in einem anderen Team auf einer alten
Programmierplattform gearbeitet hatte, der war
auch mit dazugekommen. Der konnte also auch
mit diesem Team arbeiten und das Team war wirklich
super. Wir haben so viel Spaß gehabt,
wir haben uns so gut verstanden, das war so eine richtig, richtig
eingeschworene Truppe.
Und ich wurde auch immer zu diesem Zeitpunkt
von dem Geschäftsführer sehr gut, sehr
respektvoll behandelt.
Die festangestellten Mitarbeiter,
aber nicht so wirklich. Die haben ständig doofe
Sprüche bekommen. Die wurden ständig
runtergemacht, wurden
ja fast schon gemobbt und immer
wurde gegen diese Mitarbeiter gewettert
und jeden Tag war eigentlich irgendeine Situation,
wo ich mir denke, es gibt auch schon richtig asoziale
Chefs in der Richtung. Wahrscheinlich war das
auch ein bisschen ein kleinerer Laden.
Weiß ich nicht, vielleicht habe ich nicht richtig zugehört,
ob er erzählt hat, wie groß das war.
Nur weil die namenhafte Kundenname heißt ja nicht,
dass das jetzt ein riesengroßer Laden war.
Also quasi, gerade wenn
in so einem Laden gelaufen,
in so einem Laden gelandet bist, wo der Chef
noch persönlich das alles so
observieren will,
dann ist das meistens echt ein bisschen...
Ihr kennt ja vielleicht das Video,
wo ich erzählt
habe,
wie es nach meiner Ausbildung
lief beim
Provider und was sie sich dort für
komische Dinge überlegt haben.
Warum ich dann auch da weg bin.
Aber eine Sache
ist mir aufgefallen schon.
Je schlechter der Chef,
umso
besser und eingeschworener
der
Teamzusammenhalt.
Das mag
aber auch daran liegen,
weil die halt
sich verbünden müssen.
Sonst wird das
nichts. Das heißt nicht,
dass automatisch bei einem guten Chef das Team
auch schlecht ist, aber die
Chancen, dass bei einem
richtigen Abfackchef der
Teamzusammenhalt und so,
gerade wenn es ein kleines Team ist, hoch
ist, habe ich
schon öfters beobachtet.
Ich dachte, ganz schön krass,
das kann man doch eigentlich nie machen.
Ich weiß noch, relativ am Anfang hat einer der Azubis
von seinem Azubi-Gehalt, was ja
nicht besonders üppig ist, ein iPhone
angespart. Er hatte ein Dreivierteljahr, glaube ich, gespart,
um sich dann ein iPhone kaufen zu können.
Er ist morgens ins Büro gekommen und war ganz stolz.
Das war ein goldenes iPhone.
Moment, ein goldenes
iPhone?
Er ist morgens ins Büro gekommen und war ganz stolz.
Das war ein goldenes iPhone.
Er war total happy, dass er es gemacht hat.
Er hat gezeigt, wie cool das ist und wie gut die
Kamera ist und so. Und während er
das in der Hand hatte, kam der Chef rein.
Wut entbrannt, total sauer, riss
ihm dieses Handy aus der Hand, machte das Fenster
auf und schmiss das iPhone, das neue
iPhone aus dem Fenster raus.
Alter!
Was ist mit dem los?
Anzeige ist raus.
What the fuck?
Wir waren im vierten Stock.
Vor uns war so ein großer Platz, wo
die LKWs von der Logistikfirma waren.
Und dieses iPhone ist unten auf den
Teerplatz geknallt und war natürlich im Arsch.
Und wir standen da, wie
versteinert, wie entsetzt.
Der Zubi hatte...
Du weißt in der Situation echt nicht, was du machen sollst.
Im Nachhinein
denkst du dir dann immer, das hätte
ich mir nicht gefallen lassen.
Wenn du
unvorbereitet auf einmal in so einer Situation
bist, da stehst du da und guckst
einfach nur doof.
Ich kann mir das durchaus vorstellen.
Es gibt so Leute.
Tränen in den Augen
und der Chef rannte raus.
Und wir standen immer noch da, wie angewurzelt.
Und der Chef kam wieder rein,
hatte ein Dünnel Geld in der Hand und
knallte dem Azubi 700 Euro auf den Tisch
und sagte, eins sollte er sich merken.
Er hätte Geld wie Heu, aber wenn er
Regeln machen würde, dann hätte er die zu befolgen
und er hätte in der Arbeitszeit sein Handy nicht
anzupacken.
Boah, was ein Spast, Mann.
Boah, da kriegst du ja Anfälle allein schon
vom Hören.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Es gibt so Leute.
Meine Güte, ey.
Und das sind dann die gleichen, die sich darüber
aufregen,
man findet ja keine Leute mehr.
Oder so nach dem Motto,
oh, die Jugend von heute, die
will ja gar nichts arbeiten.
Wir finden keine Leute mehr und
Wachkräfte mangelnd. Ja, bei dem Laden
will halt keiner arbeiten und die, die da
arbeiten, sind wahrscheinlich zackig wieder weg.
Die einzigen Leute,
die dort eine Weile bleiben,
das sind wahrscheinlich noch die,
die schon so lange dabei sind,
dass sie geistig da schon komplett abgeschlossen
haben mit. Azubi, immer noch
komplett perplex. Ja, verstehe.
Hat 100 Euro Benefit gemacht, aber das
iPhone hatte nur 600 Euro gekostet.
Ich glaube,
darüber konnte er sich nicht freuen.
Ist sofort meinen Schreibblock gepackt,
und bin hinter dem Geschäftsführer hergelaufen.
Bin in sein Büro gegangen und hab gesagt,
was war das denn jetzt gerade für eine Aktion?
Jetzt garantiert, wenn der
Chef auf 180 ist, der ist garantiert
jetzt nicht einsichtig. Das kann ich
euch, das ist so sicher wie das Arm in der Kirche.
Der regt sich jetzt auch noch drüber auf.
Mischen Sie sich nicht in meine Gelegenheiten an
hier, Sie sind ja noch schlimmer oder was auch immer.
Das Video ist nicht,
das Video hat Audio,
hat irgendwie Schwankungen von der
Lautstärke. Ich kann es nur auf
einen Punkt sagen, der lässt sich
garantiert nichts sagen jetzt.
Warum gehen Sie mit Ihren Mitarbeitern so rum?
Der hat nicht mit seinem Handy gespielt, der hat gestern
sein ewig angespartes iPhone gekauft und
heute Morgen ganz stolz einmal kurz gezeigt,
der hat nicht gespielt oder damit gesurft oder sonst irgendwas,
der wollte nur mal zeigen, was er für ein tolles neues
iPhone hat.
Wie ich mit meinen Mitarbeitern
rede und wie ich mein Unternehmen
führe, das lassen Sie bitte mal meine
Sorge sein. Und wenn Ihnen das nicht passt,
dann da ist die Tür.
CU und Tschüss.
Gut, konnte sich in der Situation wahrscheinlich nicht leisten,
aber
ich hätte ja eigentlich gedacht, der Chef
wäre noch ein bisschen mehr ausgeflippt.
Wenn der eh schon auf
180, ich hätte gedacht, der hätte sich jetzt
direkt,
das ist ja noch
eine halbwegs
besonnen, will ich jetzt nicht sagen,
beruhigende Antwort gewesen,
wenn auch eine Assi-Antwort,
aber ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, dass
ich jetzt erstmal weiter direkt aufregt.
So, von Ihnen lasst mir gar nichts sagen oder
was auch immer.
Es gibt echt Leute,
die sich nicht wundern müssen, dass keiner bei Ihnen
arbeiten will. Und in der heutigen
Zeit, und das ist
wahrscheinlich auch echt gut so,
kannst du dir das
nicht überall, aber in vielen Bereichen
aussuchen.
Und da musst du dir so einen Scheiß nicht geben lassen.
Das sind dann halt die gleichen Leute,
die auch immer wieder in der tollen Statistik
zum Fachkräftemangel auftauchen,
weil sie seit
drei Jahren Stellen offen haben,
die Scheiße geschrieben sind, Scheiße
bezahlt sind und eine Scheißstelle an sich ist,
plus ein Scheiß-Chef
und die keiner machen will
und die dann die ganze Zeit
jammern, oh Fachkräftemangel,
wir finden keinen und oh, das will
keiner machen, die Jugend von heute
ist so anspruchsvoll, die Jugend von heute
will überhaupt nichts arbeiten, oh die Leute,
die sind so verweichlich, so bla bla bla
bla, nein, der Laden ist einfach
Scheiße, die Bedingungen sind
Scheiße und deswegen will es keiner machen.
Oh.
Welche Option hatte ich? Ich hatte ein Kind,
was auf der Welt war schon,
zwei Monate alt war, eine Frau, die in Mutterschutz
ist. Und Leute, ich sag euch jetzt,
ich sag euch mal eins jetzt, in der
Situation, wenn man das jetzt hört
in dem Video, ja,
ich weiß, ich soll nicht so oft Pause machen,
ich muss jetzt einfach Pause machen, in solcher Situation,
jeder von euch hat sich
jetzt gedacht, oder sagt
es mir mal, nicht jeder, aber die meisten,
die meisten von euch haben sich jetzt gedacht,
Alter, sowas kannst du dir
nicht gefallen lassen, sowas würde ich
mir nicht gefallen lassen, in so einer Situation
wäre ich sofort weg.
Das ist, das ist aber
der Gedanke, den man nicht zwangsläufig
dort direkt
klar im Kopf fassen kann,
weil, wenn man
in so einer Situation ist,
denkt man nicht
in den gleichen Strukturen, wie man das jetzt
entspannt daheim vom Rechner
denkt. Das fällt dir dann
später am Tag vielleicht ein, so nach dem Motto,
Alter, das kann ich mir nicht mehr geben, den Mist,
oder so. Aber in der Situation
bist du oftmals einfach nur total überfahren
davon und weißt nicht so recht,
was du machen sollst.
Kredit für einen neu gekauften Firmenwagen.
Was würde mir gerne selbst eine Cloud
hosten, was empfehlt ihr?
Schwanke im Moment zwischen
Nextcloud und Oncloud. Ich mag beide nicht.
Oncloud ewig nicht benutzt,
Nextcloud jedes Mal, wenn ich es mir angucke,
wünsche ich mir es nicht mehr weiter
benutzen zu müssen, ja.
Ich mag Nextcloud nicht.
Ich mag Oncloud auch nicht.
Nextcloud ist so ein Ding,
ich kenn die neue Oncloud nicht, keine Ahnung,
aber Nextcloud ist so ein Ding,
das wirkt wie ein Riesenhaufen
zusammengeschusterter Software
mit zum größten Teil
gut gedacht, aber schlecht umgesetzt.
Jedes Mal,
wenn ich Nextcloud ausprobiere,
habe ich den gleichen Eindruck.
Außerdem hat Nextcloud
mit Cloud überhaupt
nichts zu tun. Außer, dass es
Cloud im Namen hat, aber Nextcloud
ist genauso wenig Cloud
wie
keine Ahnung,
wie dein
Browser.
Also Nextcloud ist nichts Cloud.
Nextcloud ist
ein Caldaff-Server,
ein bisschen File-Sync,
hat aber mit Cloud eigentlich gar nichts zu tun.
Funktioniert jetzt eigentlich gescheit
Fulltext-Search bei Nextcloud?
Also sowohl für die Dateien
als auch beispielsweise für Notizen
und sowas? Das ging ja jahrelang
nicht, ich habe es so oft ausprobiert, irgendwann
hatte ich keinen Bock mehr. Also ich weiß,
dass das prinzipiell funktioniert,
wenn du dein eigenes Elasticsearch hostest,
aber da hatte ich nie Bock drauf.
Okay, jetzt aber erstmal fertig gucken.
Und nicht wirklich viele andere Projekte,
weil ich hatte meine Selbstständigkeit
gerade erst begonnen, ich hatte zwar ein, zwei andere
kleine Kunden, aber mit denen hätte ich mich nicht über Wasser
halten können. Ich musste in diesem
Projekt bleiben. Ich war weiter darauf angewiesen,
dass ich dort quasi mein Geld verdienen konnte.
Also bin ich wieder zurück
in mein Büro.
Wir haben nicht so getan, als wenn nichts passiert wäre,
aber wir haben weitergearbeitet.
Das Klima wurde in der Folgezeit
immer schlimmer. Teilweise gegen
mich, aber ganz besonders gegen die Mitarbeiter.
Eine Story fällt mir da gerade noch ein, mir fallen
viele Storys ein, aber die kann man fast
alle nicht erzählen. Aber die Story,
da waren wir in einem Meeting und einer von
meinen Entwicklern, der älteste Entwickler,
der hatte Kinder, zwei Stück, und der hat ganz stolz
erzählt, dass sie über die letzten Monate auch
Geld angespart haben, um dem Sohn zum
Geburtstag oder zu Weihnachten, ich weiß nicht mehr genau,
ein Trampolin zu kaufen. Dass die er und seine Frau
immer was zurückgelegt haben, weil die hatten nicht
viel Geld. Und dass auch die Großeltern was dazu
beigetragen haben und jetzt konnten sie für
380 Euro, glaube ich, dieses Trampolin
kaufen. Er hat gesagt, er hätte gerne noch 100 Euro
mehr angespart, weil dann hätten sie ein Trampolin
kaufen können, wo auf diesen Sprungfedern noch so
eine Abdeckung da wäre, weil die anderen sind ein bisschen
gefährlich, wenn das Kind da mit dem Bein reinkommt.
Und dann komme ich um
die Ecke und spring da drauf und
dann ist es kaputt.
Ja, das würde ich dem Trampolin nicht zumuten
wollen. Das hätte es leider nicht gereicht.
Ich weiß nicht, der Geschäftsführer da saß
und hat so einen Sakko an, hat den Sakko aufgemacht,
hat so einen Bündel Geldscheine rausgeholt
und hat dann angefangen zu zählen und hat dann
den Namen des
Mitarbeiters gesagt.
Okay, hätte
er vorher die Story nicht erzählt
und auch das jetzt so nicht erzählt,
hätte ich fast vermuten können,
der Chef
hat gesagt, wissen Sie was, kaufen Sie sich ein ordentliches
Trampolin, hier haben Sie 150 Euro.
Aber das hat er höchstwahrscheinlich
nicht gemacht.
Und außerdem,
warum hat der ein Bündel Geldscheine dabei?
Das ist natürlich die Frage.
Über Geld spricht man nicht, Geld hat man.
Oh, cringe.
Überhaupt nicht.
Alter, der Typ hat doch echt
psychische Probleme, oder?
Der hat doch wirklich
irgendeinen Schaden.
Das sind so Leute,
die ich, ich weiß, das ist jetzt was ganz
was anderes, das sind so Leute
mit diesen Sprüchen, die ich so mit
richtig den krassesten Boomer
Facebook-Gruppen in Verbindung bringe.
So die
die boomerigsten
Facebook-Gruppen, die man sich vorstellen kann.
Da ist der wahrscheinlich drinne.
Der Chef.
So ein typischer,
also es wird hart cringe
jetzt, Leute.
Das sind Facebook-Gruppen,
wo Witze gepostet werden,
sinngemäß.
Ich komm da drauf, weil das hat mal,
das hab ich mal auf Twitter gelesen,
da hat einer einen Screenshot aus so einer Facebook-Gruppe
gepostet.
Und da hab ich mir gedacht,
Alter, ich kann nie so alt werden,
dass ich jemals in so einer,
also ich bin ja nicht bei Facebook am Start,
aber ich kann glaube ich niemals so alt werden,
dass ich jemals in so einer Facebook-Gruppe lande.
Zum Thema so
Boomer-Sprüche und Boomer-Humor.
Da war Ostern.
Und auf Facebook,
die Boomer-Gruppen haben sie überschlagen
mit
extrem unlustigen Boomer-Memes.
Und einer hat
ein Bild gepostet,
und da stand sinngemäß drauf,
Haha, es ist Ostern.
Alle wissen doch,
an Ostern sucht man keine
Eiern, sondern man spielt mit ihnen.
Und dann das Teufel-Emoji dahinter.
Und da hab ich mir gedacht,
so eine extrem
cringe dumme
Message, Mann.
Das ist so typische Boomer-Facebook-
Gruppen-Humor. Und genau
in solchen Facebook-Gruppen ist
wahrscheinlich dieser Chef, Mann.
Wo
alles, was gepostet wird,
schon so weh tut
vom puren Lesen.
Ja, genau, genau.
So Leute
tun echt weh.
Und wie gesagt,
diese Storys, ich könnte, das Video würde
dann zu lang werden, ich könnte die ganze Zeit weitererzählen.
Irgendwann dann, wollte ich ein Whiteboard
für mein Team haben. Denn wir waren
mittlerweile mitten im Projekt drin und ich wollte gerne,
dass wir nach Scrum oder Ken werden arbeiten. Und dafür brauchen
wir ein Taskboard. Also hab ich dann beim
Chef das Whiteboard...
Das ist deutlich zu modern und
agil für den Chef, sowas.
Das geht ja nicht. Zumal,
stellt euch mal vor, agil mit dem
Chef, dann hat er ja
nicht auf jeden Einzelnen einen direkten
Blick, was der jetzt zu welcher Sekunde
macht. Das kann der nicht abhaben.
Agiles Entwickeln
mit dem Chef, im Leben nicht.
Entwickler machen selbst
ein Backlog, suchen sich selbst
das raus. Er kann zwar ab und zu
mal ein bisschen priorisieren, aber ansonsten
im Leben klappt das mit diesem
Chef nicht.
Beantragt, genehmigt bekommen, ist auch ein Unternehmen gekommen,
hat das an der Wand aufgehangen.
Und wir haben dann angefangen mit Scrum zu arbeiten.
Irgendwann haben wir einen Sprint gehabt und dieser Sprint
war, nee, wir haben drei Sprints gehabt, die wir
nicht auf Null geschafft haben,
also wo wir nicht alles geschafft haben, was wir uns vorgenommen hatten.
Ich meine, eigentlich ist es ja fast normal, dass du nicht
alles immer komplett auf Null... Wie sieht das bei
euren Sprints aus, Chatgy? Seid ihr da
immer auf Null? Also ich glaube,
ich habe in letzter Zeit keinen Sprint erlebt, wo
es auf Null war. Es gibt so die üblichen
Tickets, die von einem
Sprint in den nächsten verschoben werden und,
ah ja, das ist wichtig, das müssen wir jetzt eigentlich auch machen.
Ah, nächster Sprint, ah, das ist nicht fertig
geworden, aber das ist wichtig, das müssen wir jetzt eigentlich machen.
Ah, Moment,
nächster Sprint, ah, Moment, aber das ist wichtig, das müssen
wir jetzt eigentlich wirklich mal fertig machen.
Ja, genau,
theoretisch kannst du ja da noch,
du kannst ja total übertreiben, du kannst
dann Sprint,
Review, Sprint, Retrospektive,
Sprintplanung und alle
möglichen Agilitätsdinger
bis zum Umkippen
machen, aber auf Null
ist wirklich selten, ne?
Sprint hatten wir 15% zu wenig geschafft,
weil mittendrin die Anforderungen vom Chef geändert
wurden und die Priorisierung anders gelaufen ist.
Auf jeden Fall hat das nicht
gepasst. Nach dem Review sind wir wieder in unser
Büro gegangen
und es dauerte fünf Minuten und dann kam
der Chef rein. Wieder Wut entbrannt
und hatte einen Barhocker dabei und hat
sich aus dem Aufenthaltsraum mitgenommen
und hat von einer Sekunde auf die nächste angefangen
wie so eine wild
gewordene Tarantel auf dieses
Whiteboard einzudreschen mit diesem Barhocker.
Fuck, Alter, was geht mit
dem Kerl ab, man? Also der ist doch
echt psychisch gestört, oder?
Und wir standen wieder alle da, komplett
entsetzt und der hat die ganze Zeit, gefühlt
fünf Minuten, auf dieses Whiteboard eingedroschen.
Und als es dann komplett vermackt war
und teilweise gerissen war,
hat er angefangen
an diesem Whiteboard zu rumpen und wollte das von der
Wand rumpen. Oh! Und ich weiß noch
wie der älteste Entwickler, der erfahrenere
Kollege, sich eine Zigarette
angezündet hat. Wir haben da in dem Büro geraucht.
Okay, ist auf jeden Fall schon ein bisschen her.
Einmal eine Zigarette gezogen hat, dann seine Schreibtischschublade
aufgemacht hat und so ein langes Metallstück
rausgeholt. Ich glaube, es war ein Lineal.
Dann ist er mit der Zigarette zu dem tobenen
Chef hingegangen und hat gesagt,
Chefe, nimm das hier, sonst hast du es morgen
wieder am Rücken.
Oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott.
Oh mein Gott.
Aber wir waren immer noch da.
Nur weil er manche Sachen
richtig macht, heißt das nicht, dass automatisch
alles richtig sein muss.
Also es kann durchaus sein, dass er die ein oder andere
guten Entscheidungen mal getroffen hat oder vielleicht noch trifft.
Aus Business Enterprise
Stonks Sicht.
Ich war finanziell immer noch abhängig.
Das war jetzt zeitlich nicht so weit von dem letzten Vorfall weg.
Ich hatte immer noch nicht wirklich
mehr neue Projekte,
die mir hätten Geld in die Kasse
gespült. Ich musste in diesem Projekt bleiben.
Irgendwann dann hat er ein Kollege aus
einem Nachbarbüro. Das ist
eine scheiß Situation. Eigentlich
willst du da bloß noch weg bei sowas.
Also ich glaube,
ich glaube ernsthaft,
die ersten paar Dinge,
das kann ich gut nachvollziehen,
dass er einfach nur noch geschockt ist und erstmal nicht so genau
weiß, was er machen soll. Aber spätestens, wenn
im Büro jemand mit Sachen
um sich schlägt,
dann hätte ich mir echt
überlegt, wie man dagegen vorgehen
kann. Jetzt
nicht irgendwie, um
die Sache da noch zu retten, sondern
um mich da zu retten.
Ob man dann irgendwie argumentieren
kann,
krank melden oder
psychisch, du hast
Angst auf die Arbeit zu gehen, du hast Angst, dass
dein Chef dich körperlich
misshandelt
und
die Chance, wenn du in dem Raum stehst,
kommt einer rein mit dem Barhocker und schlägt da wild
um sich, also dann ist
die Angst ja sicherlich nicht unbegründet.
Was
sicherlich auch
an anderen Stellen echt Probleme
geben kann für das Unternehmen,
wenn da sowas ist.
Also ich denke mal, zumindest
Krankschreiben sich was Neues suchen,
wenn man denn so weit abgeschlossen hat
damit, wäre mit sowas durchaus
möglich. Dann wirst du bestimmt genug
Ärzte finden, die das direkt einsehen.
Und ansonsten, ich
wäre mir nicht sicher, ich
wahrscheinlich wäre das der Fall der Fälle
gewesen, wo ich
tatsächlich auch mal einen Anwalt aufgesucht
hätte, was Arbeitsrecht angeht.
Ich bin da mittlerweile
auf dem, also
an dem Punkt angelangt, dass
wenn es irgendwas gibt,
was ich machen muss,
sei es jetzt
irgendwie mit einer Versicherung
oder organisatorisch
oder sonst was und da gibt es Leute, die das
besser können, dann lasse ich die das machen.
Deswegen habe ich einen Steuerberater mittlerweile,
deswegen habe ich jetzt bei der Versicherungsgeschichte
habe ich das direkt einen Anwalt machen lassen
und ich bin jetzt dazu übergegangen,
anstatt echt
teilweise
drei Wochen sich durchs Internet zu kämpfen,
sich komische Ratschläge auf Reddit
zu holen oder noch schlimmer gutefrage.de
oder so ein Müll.
Einfach mal, wenn es was
ist, wo es tatsächlich Experten gibt
und man auch Sachen
findet mit guten Bewertungen in der Nähe,
das mal da zu probieren.
Also
da hätte ich tatsächlich glaube ich
spätestens dran gedacht, wie sieht es denn mal mit
einem Anwalt aus, der sich mit
arbeitsrechtlichen Sachen auskennt und
spätestens da
hätte ich da aufwecken müssen.
Je nachdem was sie da haben,
wenn es halt ein kleiner Laden ist, komplett ohne
Betriebsrat oder wo es halt außer dem
Chef sonst nichts gibt.
Schwierig dort auf
dem Weg was zu machen.
Aber ist echt nicht.
Also spätestens da ist
wirklich grenzwertig.
Da musst du ja wirklich Angst haben, dass du
da mal mit Verletzungen raus gehst.
Ende
50 Anfang 60 ein Herzinfarkt.
Moment, jetzt habe ich vergessen,
nicht vergessen, habe ich überhört. Was war jetzt?
Die hätten Geld in die Kasse gespült, ich musste
in diesem Projekt bleiben. Irgendwann dann
hatte ein Kollege aus dem Nachbarbüro
Ende 50 Anfang 60
ein Herzinfarkt zu Hause.
Und morgens im Meeting hat dann der Chef
erzählt, dass der Kollege
einen Herzinfarkt hatte. Und wir waren alle schockiert,
entsetzt, betroffen, könnt ihr euch ja vorstellen.
Und er sagte einfach nur
seid froh, dass das nicht hier im Büro
passiert ist, weil so eine warme Leiche,
die da rumliegt, da hat jetzt wirklich keiner Bock drauf.
Ich sage euch Leute,
der Chef ist in den boomerigsten
Facebook-Gruppen unterwegs.
Das ist so typischer
Geschmack
Ultra, also
du musst eh schon
immer gerne dein Leben lang
geschmacklose Sprüche gebracht haben,
dass du sowas machen kannst.
Selbst,
ich meine okay, wenn er es sich denkt,
ist schon fragwürdig.
Aber denken kann jeder, was er will.
Aber das dann auch noch so zu sagen,
ich kann mir
den Kerl wirklich in den passenden
Facebook-Gruppen vorstellen und den ganzen Tag
solche blöden Sprüche kloppen.
Und ich saß hier, weil so eine warme Leiche,
die da rumliegt, da hat jetzt wirklich keiner Bock drauf.
Und ich saß da und war
total angewidert.
Was machst du hier eigentlich?
Das kannst du doch echt nicht sein.
Der Kollege kam dann irgendwann nach
Wochen, Monaten, ich weiß nicht mehr genau,
wieder. Er hat erst so eine Wiedereinwiderung
gehabt, das heißt, er hat, glaube ich, zwei Tage die Woche
irgendwie drei oder vier Stunden gearbeitet.
Und ich war im Urlaub und
den ersten Tag nach meinem Urlaub war ich
in meinem Büro, ich saß direkt neben der Glastür und konnte
durch die Glastür in das Büro
von den Kollegen gucken. Und dieser ältere
Kollege saß mit dem Rücken zur Tür
und auf der gegenüberliegenden Seite war ein anderer Kollege.
Und da machte der Chef sich
einen Spaß daraus, sich von hinten
in das Büro zu schleichen und diesen
Mitarbeiter, der Wochen
davor einen Herzinfarkt hatte,
zu erschrecken. Alter, jetzt wird's ja langsam
schon kriminell, Mann.
Und als er dann sich beruhigt hatte,
hat er gesagt, er sollte keine Sorge, ich weiß nicht
mehr genau, wie es genau war, sinngemäß,
er sollte sich keine Sorgen machen, wenn er noch mal
einen Herzinfarkt kriegen würde, dann würde er schon wieder
beleben.
Oh, Alter,
was, Leute! Ich weiß noch, wie
auf 580 ich war, dass ich zum ersten
Mal bei all diesen Eskapaden
aus dem Firmengebäude gegangen bin und draußen
eine Zigarette geraucht habe, weil ich echt
wow, gekocht habe.
Wenn der jetzt noch einen zweiten Herzinfarkt gehabt hätte,
der andere Typ, da hätte er sich wahrscheinlich noch drüber
lustig gemacht. Weiß nicht, was ich dazu
sagen soll noch. Nach dem Mittagessen
habe ich meine Frau angerufen,
habe das erzählt,
mittlerweile Frau, und da hat sie gesagt,
David, ganz ehrlich, pack deine Klamotten
und hau da ab. Wir kriegen
das irgendwie hin, wir kriegen irgendwie
Christo-Aufträge, wenn du dich da hauptberuflich
erstmal um die Kundenakquise kümmerst.
Seit er weg ist, ist es wahrscheinlich noch
eine Nummer schlimmer geworden.
Aber das
haben wir nicht nötig und das kannst du
nicht mehr mit ihm machen lassen. Ich bin dann zurück
gekommen, habe mich von meinem Team, von
einem Kollegen verabschiedet, bin zum Chef gegangen,
habe meinen Stundenzettel, meinen letzten
abzeichnen lassen, war auch gar nicht
überrascht und hat dann gesagt,
David, darf ich dir für deine weitere Karriere
als Selbstständiger noch einen guten Tipp mit auf den Weg geben?
Jetzt hat er gesagt, Halt's Maul, du Kackspast.
Nee, hat er wahrscheinlich nicht
gesagt, aber
wäre vielleicht nicht unangebracht gewesen.
Habe ihn angeguckt, habe gesagt,
nee, brauchst du nicht. Ja, genau.
Sehr, sehr wertvollen Tipp und eine ganz wertvolle
Lektion gezeigt. Habe meine Klamotten
gepackt und bin
nach Hause gefahren. Und ich weiß noch,
als ich die Treppe runtergegangen bin, das waren
vier Etagen, vier Treppen oder acht Treppen,
weil es immer so geteilt war, und ich habe mir bei
jeder Stufe gefühlt geschworen,
nie wieder arbeitest du für
so jemanden, für so jemanden, der mit
seinen Mitarbeitern, mit dir
oder generell mit anderen so umgeht,
die so respektlos, so würdelos
behandelt, der die Leute
so mobbt. Niemals
wieder. Also da muss ich sagen,
ich hatte ja ein ähnliches Erlebnis,
also war weitem nicht so
krass wie das hier, muss man mal sagen.
Aber ich hatte ja auch, aber kein
ähnliches, war falsch formuliert, aber auch
so ein
Erlebnis mit dem ehemaligen
Chef, da wo ich meine Ausbildung gemacht habe,
in dem Betrieb.
Und also ich war
da noch kurze Zeit nach der Ausbildung,
da habe ich sogar ein Video drüber gemacht.
Das erste,
ich weiß es nicht mehr,
das war ein Plants vs. Zombies Gameplay,
im Hintergrund,
da war es nicht Kündigung,
das war
genau wo ich erzählt habe,
hier.
So Leute, jetzt ist es.
Das da ist es, glaube ich.
Und zwar, unser alter Teamleiter ist
ja weg. Ja, genau, das ist das.
Da habe ich ja auch ein bisschen drüber
erzählt, wie sie dann versucht haben,
die Leute da zu drangsalieren
mit
persönlichen
Gesprächen,
so nach dem Motto,
Einzelgespräche, wo man dann
rausfinden wollte.
Das war ganz wirr. Also
wen es interessiert, der kann sich das ja mal anhören.
Und das, als ich da weg war,
also nicht direkt, als ich da
weg war, erst tatsächlich ein paar Jahre
später, habe ich mir auch überlegt,
Max, also nachdem ich
das auch erst mal anders kannte und so,
wenn du sowas zum ersten Mal erlebst,
weißt du dann nicht so richtig damit anzufangen.
Und das hat auch ein paar
Jahre gedauert und dann habe ich mir gedacht, also das machst du
nie wieder mit.
Da hatten wir einen Teambuilding Workshop,
wo es im Prinzip nicht um Teambuilding ging,
sondern den Leuten zu erzählen,
dass sie halt scheiße sind und das, was
der Chef sagt, prinzipiell das Geilste ist.
Also das war der Sinn des Teambuilding Workshops.
Habe ich alles in dem Video erzählt.
Das sind so Dinger, das würde ich
heute nicht mehr machen.
Da würde ich heute nicht mehr dran teilnehmen.
Würde ich heute
wahrscheinlich einfach sagen, also
unter den Bedingungen sehe ich das hier nicht.
Kein Mehrwert da
für alle Beteiligten drin. Also ich nehme
da nicht dran teil. Und wenn es dann halt
jemanden überaufregen will, soll er es machen.
Aber das
braucht eine Weile,
bis man
auch mal realisiert hat.
Ich meine in dem Fall,
was er erzählt, war es klar.
Aber
manchmal ist es ja im Kopf
nicht so klar,
zumindest für einen selbst,
wo es dran gelegen hat.
Also sprich, ob das
ein Problem von einem selber ist
oder ob das Verhalten
quasi wirklich scheiße war.
Manchmal braucht man erstmal
so ein bisschen Abstand und braucht ein paar
Jahre vielleicht noch Erfahrung in irgendeinem
anderen Betrieb und so, bis man dann zu der
Realisierung kommt, okay,
das war echt beschissenes Verhalten
von einem Arbeitgeber
und es lag nicht
an dir, dass du da irgendwie
das
so komisch vorgekommen ist.
Dass dir das so merkwürdig vorgekommen ist.
Das war wirklich merkwürdig.
Das lag nicht an dir, dass dir das merkwürdig vorgekommen ist.
Das war wirklich merkwürdig und
das war wirklich nicht in Ordnung, das so zu machen.
Das braucht manchmal so ein bisschen.
Und deswegen kann ich das voll und ganz verstehen,
dass die Leute
einfach nur geschockt waren, als er am Anfang
das iPhone aus dem Fenster geschmissen hat und nicht genau
wissen, was sie machen sollten.
Man wird einfach nach der Zeit... Genau das ist es.
Man wird einfach nach
einer Zeit ein bisschen schlauer. Das schlimmt.
Ich habe
eine kleine Macke
davon getragen.
Sowohl von der Zeit...
Da müssen jetzt, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen
mein aktueller Chef drunter leiden,
beziehungsweise der drüber und
vielleicht auch ein paar Teammitglieder.
Ich habe so eine kleine Macke
davon getragen, sowohl von der
Zeit beim Provider, wo sie sich echt
sehr weirdchampig verhalten
haben, als auch
von
den unterirdischen
Chefs, die ich hatte beim letzten
Arbeitgeber bei der Bank.
Zum Glück bin ich jetzt bei der
Versicherung gelandet.
So eine kleine Macke habe ich davon
getragen und zwar
schwer zu beschreiben und zwar
je nachdem, gerade
an Tagen, wo ich eh schon nicht so gut drauf bin.
Es gibt ja auch durchaus Sachen außerhalb
von der Arbeit, weshalb man mal nicht gut drauf
sein kann. Ich...
Wie sage ich das jetzt am besten?
Was ist die Macke, die ich davon getragen habe?
Also, ich nehme manche Sachen
zu ernst.
Ne, das ist falsch.
Ich interpretiere
in manche Sachen
zu viel
negative
Erwartungen rein, die es gar nicht gibt.
Also sprich,
mal angenommen, ich bin
an dem Tag eh schon schlecht drauf.
Und
mich ruft irgendwie der
Bankleiter an und fragt
Max, sag mal, wie sieht denn das
da und damit aus?
Normalerweise müsste mir einer dann von ausgehen,
ey, der will einfach
nur meinen Status wissen und
gut ist, ja, gar nichts wildes.
Aber teilweise
durch die Erfahrung, die ich bei den letzten Läden
gemacht habe, reicht mir schon
die Frage danach,
dass ich mir jetzt denke, okay,
der hat irgendwas vor
und sei es nur,
dass er
dir da irgendwie den Strick draus drehen will,
dass du dein Ticket nicht richtig aktualisiert hast
oder sowas.
Das ist aber, gerade
in dem Laden, wo ich jetzt bin, das ist aber gar nicht
so. Okay, wenn ihr das auch kennt,
habe ich das, glaube ich, ganz gut beschrieben.
Das ist aber
meistens gar nicht so.
Ich bin aber
echt davon meistens dann so
bauchgefühlmäßig überzeugt,
dass das so sein muss.
Und ich glaube,
das ist so eine kleine Macke,
die ich so von den letzten paar Läden
davongetragen habe, weil ich da auch
durchaus einige sehr unfähige Führungskräfte
hatte.
Obwohl das gar nicht gemeint ist,
sagt mir mein Bauchgefühl dazu, das ist so
gemeint.
Das muss überhaupt nicht der Hintergedanke
davon sein und ist es wahrscheinlich auch gar
nicht. Das muss ich mir dann
auch immer sagen, da muss ich mir mal kurz überlegen,
der hat dich nicht gefragt, weil er dich nerven
will. Der hat dich auch nicht gefragt, weil
er dir demnächst erzählen will,
hier, das ist kacke gelaufen oder so.
Der wollte wahrscheinlich schlicht und ergreifend
wirklich einfach nur wissen, was Sache
ist.
Aber gut, wenn ihr das auch kennt.
Ja, und
das führt dann halt auch dazu,
dass ich mich, dadurch, dass ich
so negative Absichten
schon reininterpretiere,
dass ich
mich dann schnell
auch
ja, ähm
verarscht ist das falsche Wort,
schnell nicht für voll
genommen fühle,
wenn sowas ist, so nach dem Motto
ich hab doch gesagt, wie es ist, warum
werde ich jetzt noch dreimal gefragt, so nach dem Motto,
wisst ihr, dabei meinen die das
überhaupt nicht böse.
Ja, ja, sowas in der Richtung
vielleicht, ja. Wie heißt
das Video zum Teambuilding-Event?
Ähm.
Das hier, warum ich meinen Job kündig
habe, dass das Thumbnail ist, wenn der Chef
dich verarscht. Und es gibt
eine Sache, da habe ich,
ich weiß nicht, woran es liegt, aber das ist so eine,
da
habe ich sie vielleicht auch nicht mehr alle,
ja. Es gibt eine Sache, die
die wurmt mich immer.
Vielleicht kennt das auch einer von euch,
aber vielleicht ist das auch so ein ITler
Ding oder so, ich weiß es nicht.
Und es ist schon
viel besser geworden, die letzten Jahre.
Ich habe
echt Probleme damit,
wenn einer,
und auch wenn er es gar nicht so
meint, mit
irgendwelchen dummen Sprüchen
meine Kompetenz
in technischen Sachen infrage stellt.
Der mag sogar recht
damit haben. Und ich weiß selbst, dass
ich von viel mehr, und das wissen wir alle,
keine Ahnung habe,
wie von Sachen, die ich Ahnung habe.
Aber wenn es ein Thema ist,
wovon ich Ahnung habe,
und irgendwo macht irgendwie einer einen Spruch,
in den man reininterpretieren könnte,
dass ich keinen Plan
von dem Thema habe, obwohl ich davon Ahnung
habe, das nervt mich auch immer.
Und die Leute meinen das oftmals gar nicht so.
Und ich weiß, dass ich das umgedreht
bestimmt genauso oft mache, weil ich
ich mache nur wirklich viele
blöde Bemerkungen zwischendurch.
Aber kennt ihr das? Das ist teilweise
so richtig, man
interpretiert da manchmal viel mehr rein, als
eigentlich da ist.
Und ich rede jetzt nicht nur
von Führungskräften. Zum Beispiel,
machen wir mal ein Ding.
Okay.
Ich hatte letztens so eine Situation,
und ich weiß, dass der das
überhaupt nicht so meint.
In letzter Situation
bei uns im Cluster war es abgekackt.
Und
nichts großartig
will es.
Und
das ging
dann wieder, und dann kam dann die Frage
nach dem Motto,
soll
wir das Problemticket schließen, oder
nicht?
Und da habe ich dann
geschrieben im Chat, nee,
lass mal,
lass mich erstmal in die Logs reingucken,
bevor wir irgendwas weitergeben oder schließen,
dass wir nachgucken
können,
dass ich nachgucken kann, was eigentlich
los ist. So, dann mache ich
Logs auf, und
ja, ich mische jetzt ein paar Vorfälle zusammen,
um das besser erklären zu können, ja.
Und
dann,
da können die Leute gar nichts dafür,
und die meinen das auch nicht so, aber das ist
was, was mich immer ein bisschen
ärgert ist. So, zumindest ich habe geschrieben,
okay, ich gucke mal in die Logs rein,
und bevor wir irgendwas weitergeben
oder schließen,
und dann hat es keine zwei Minuten
gedauert, also ich habe ganz klar gesagt,
ich will mal in die Logs gucken, so,
und
dann hat es keine zwei Minuten
gedauert, bis jemand anderes
geschrieben hat,
ach, hier, guck mal,
habe ich, Output habe ich
schon gecheckt, du kannst das Ticket
schließen. Sowas nervt
mich. Sowas nervt
mich immer, weil wenn ich sage,
lass das Ticket mal in Ruhe,
bis ich in die Logs geguckt habe,
bevor wir das zumachen oder
weitergeben,
dann will ich kein Wettrennen
mit jemand anderem machen müssen,
für die nächste
Statusmeldung.
Ich weiß, die Leute meinen das nicht so,
das ist überhaupt nichts Schlimmes,
aber das sind so Singer, die nerven
mich immer. Das ist nichts, wo ich mir jetzt
wochenlang Gedanken mache, aber das nervt mich
immer. Dann sollen sie gefälligst halt
die Finger von diesem Ticket
weglassen, bis ich
gesagt habe, okay,
ich habe nachgeguckt,
ich finde nichts, oder
es ist nicht schlimm, oder ich habe das Problem
raus, das und das und das, bevor die
das Ticket zumachen.
Versteht ihr, was ich meine?
Ich glaube,
das sind so First-World-Problems, aber
ich glaube, man kann es ganz
gut nachvollziehen.
Das Ticket war ja schon
so ein bisschen free for all im Endeffekt,
das gehörte nicht mir,
aber ich meine,
das ist halt so ein Beispiel,
wo ich mir auch denke,
eigentlich, du meinst, das liegt an mir?
Oder wie
meinst du das? Also, das liegt mit Sicherheit
an mir, ja? Also,
das liegt mit Sicherheit an mir.
Aber es ist so ein Ding,
also,
das würde ich ja verstehen,
wenn man eine Viertelstunde
wartet, oder 20 Minuten wartet,
wenn
der Max sich da nicht meldet
und sagt, okay, dass man dann mal fragt,
sag mal, Max, hast du deine Logs jetzt endlich mal
fertig geguckt, oder
hast du es vergessen, oder so?
Das ist ja okay, aber
so dieses, ach, guck mal,
ich habe das schneller als du gefunden,
obwohl es vielleicht was ganz anderes sein kann,
mach doch das Ticket schon mal zu,
das sind so Dinge, das geht mir immer echt
auf den Keks, ja? Und wir haben auch
Leute auf der Arbeit, und ich weiß, die meinen
das überhaupt nicht böse,
deswegen sage ich dann
da auch nichts, weil die es echt nicht böse
meinen, und das in
ihrer Welt eigentlich sogar gut gemeint
ist. Zum Beispiel gibt es,
wir haben Leute, die gucken mal ganz
gerne in
andere Leute Tickets rein.
Ich mache so was
gar nicht, ich finde auch, lass
die Leute ihre eigenen Sachen machen,
aber manchmal hat das
durchaus einen sinnvollen Hintergrund.
Zum Beispiel, um
Leute darauf hinzuweisen, ey,
guck mal, das hatten wir bei der alten
Arbeit auch, Leute, die das gerne
gemacht haben, um die Leute
darauf hinzuweisen, ey, guck mal, ich habe
gesehen, dein eines Tickets steht
drei Tage vor der Eskalationsstufe
XY. Das ist
eigentlich zu 99%
von den Leuten
einfach nur nett gemeint, ja?
Aber,
wenn ich einen schlechten Tag habe,
geht mir das schon enorm auf den Sack,
wenn jemand mir sagt,
was ich mit meinen Tickets machen soll.
Und selbst, wenn ich am nächsten Tag
einen Anruf von meinem Chef kriege,
da ich das Ticket nicht richtig bearbeitet habe,
nervt es mich dann trotzdem,
dass mich einer darauf hinweist,
so nach dem Motto, Max, guck mal,
dein Ticket ist
nicht rechtzeitig bearbeitet.
Wie gesagt,
das ist, glaube ich, echt so ein Schaden,
den ich von den letzten zwei Arbeitgebern
davongetragen habe,
weil ich zu viel
negative Absichten
in eigentlich nett gemeinte
Sachen reininterpretiere.
So, lange noch,
lange Rede, kurzer Sinn,
ich habe sie nicht mehr alle.
Okay, wir gucken jetzt schnell echt noch
das Video fertig.
Und das geht noch sechs Minuten.
Wie soll ich das hinkriegen? Ich muss ins Bett.
Ich habe in den letzten 15 Jahren ganz oft
an dieses Projekt zurückgedacht.
Sehr oft. Und ich habe zu vielen Kollegen
von damals immer noch sehr, sehr guten Kontakt.
Manche haben das Unternehmen gewechselt,
aber es sind auch einige dageblieben.
Ich war damals Mitte 20.
Mein Start ins Leben, ins Berufsleben
ging damals erst los. Mein Nachwuchs stand an,
meine Ehe stand an oder meine
Eheschließung stand an. Ich hatte mich gerade
erst selbstständig gemacht. Eigentlich ging damals
das Ganze erst los. Auftragsmäßig
war ich natürlich damals noch nicht wirklich
solide aufgestellt. Ich habe nur diesen einen
großen Auftrag gehabt, von dem ich
finanziell abhängig war. Aber ganz besonders
war ich menschlich, war ich persönlich
noch nicht mal ansatzweise so weit,
wie ich heute war. Ich war jung,
ich war noch unsicher.
Ich habe nicht die Stärke und Souveränität
gehabt, die ich heute habe.
Ich glaube, dass das, was ich vorher
umschreiben wollte, mit manchen Sachen
kann man auch erst rückblickend so richtig
einschätzen.
Und es ist
gar nicht...
Wenn man solche Videos sieht, da denkt
man sich sofort, ey, in
dieser Situation hätte ich dem
Chef erst mal so richtig auf den Tisch gekackt,
so sinngemäß.
Aber es ist in der Situation
gar nicht so einfach, wenn man dann wirklich in so einem
Büro steht,
sich
zu irgendeiner
Handlung durchzuringen. Da ist man erst mal
komplett verwirrt und steht einfach nur da.
Ich damals
nicht in der Schusslinie von dem
Geschäftsführer gestanden habe. Ich hätte mich
mehr vor das Team stellen müssen.
Ich hätte mich vor allen Dingen auch mehr vor die Azubis
stellen müssen. Aber ich habe mich damals einfach
nicht dazu in der Lage gesehen.
Man traut sich ja auch nicht unbedingt.
Ich meine ganz im Ernst.
Du hast da einen Typ, der
schlägt mit Stühlen um sich.
Das erfordert eine gewisse Überwindung,
da was zu sagen.
Nicht, dass der demnächst noch den Stuhl dir
gegen den Kopf schmeißt.
Von der Persönlichkeit her nicht.
Man traut sich da auch, wenn man
das gewohnt ist, schlicht und ergreifend nicht.
Auch nicht finanziell.
Aber seit damals habe ich mir geschworen,
dass ich niemals wieder für so
jemanden arbeiten werde. Dass ich
niemals wieder in meinen Projekten
meinem
Team oder jemandem, der in meinem Projekt
arbeitet, so etwas wieder
fahren lasse. Ohne, dass ich mich wehre. Ohne, dass
ich mich versuche für diese Leute einzusetzen.
Nie wieder. Vor vier Wochen dann
hat mich ein Geschäftsführer kontaktiert.
Dieser Geschäftsführer,
es war der Geschäftsführer von damals,
hatte große Probleme in der Softwareentwicklung.
Alles war problematisch. Anforderungen,
Architektur.
Es wurde nicht in Time entwickelt. Die Kunden waren
unzufrieden. Bugs ohne Ende.
Und er hat mich gebeten, ein Mandat zu übernehmen.
In der Beratung verteilt man immer Mandate,
dass quasi jemand damit beauftragt wird,
dass man quasi das Unternehmen analysiert,
umkrempelt, alle möglichen Maßnahmen
erlässt etc. Und ich habe mir
Projektunterlagen schicken lassen.
Scrumberichte, Sprintberichte,
Anforderungslisten, Backlogs.
Diagonales, vertikales
Skalieren. Das ist ein Projekt, bei dem
ich helfen kann, bei dem ich
Chancen auf Erfolg
sehe. Und wir haben dann ein Meeting
vereinbart. Ein Meeting per Microsoft
Teams. Und als erstes kam
in dieses Meeting zwei Entwicklungsleiter.
Und von der ersten Sekunde an haben die auf mich
einen unglaublich eingeschüchterten,
nervösen Eindruck gemacht. Und ich habe das gar
nicht verstanden. Und nach einer Minute
kam der Geschäftsführer dazu.
Und dann habe ich gemerkt, was
uns gleich erwarten wird.
Das ist immer ein ganz schlechtes Zeichen.
Das habe ich auch schon erlebt.
Und das merkst du.
Da schwebt immer so eine gewisse
Wie soll man sagen?
Atmosphäre mit.
Wo du merkst,
die Leute können jetzt nicht
so wie sie wollen.
Und
trauen sich auch nicht richtig und sind
sehr bedacht darauf, jetzt ja nichts
zu sagen.
Das merkt man.
Das habe ich auch schon.
Ich musste auf der alten Arbeit öfters
mal meinen Chef vertreten,
was Abteilungsrunden
und so anging.
Abteilungsübergreifende Runden.
Und dort gab es Abteilungsleiter,
die eingeladen haben.
Bei denen war das ganz extrem.
Das hast du direkt gemerkt.
Die Leute, die da gesessen haben,
die waren
super angespannt und wollten
ja nichts Falsches sagen.
Und das merkst du dann immer daran,
also
eine Sache,
woran man das merkt, ist,
die
machen dann so super
auf
komplette
Konfliktvermeidung.
Was ja auch verständlich ist.
Konfliktvermeidung ist ja gut
im Arbeitsumfeld.
Wenn halt was...
Es sollte eigentlich
kein Konflikt sein, wenn man sagt,
hier, Service XY
ist ausgefallen.
Das und das haben wir uns als Maßnahme
überlegt, wie man das verbessern kann.
Das sollte ja kein Konflikt sein.
Aber wenn sowas schon Konflikte
verursacht, dann wird halt auch
versucht, sowas zu vermeiden.
Und das ist
ganz weird. Das waren dann
Abteilungsrunden.
Da kam dann der Typ rein,
wo man halt genau wusste, vor dem haben sie Schiss.
Und wenn der dann irgendeinen Witz gemacht hat,
haben sie alle mitgemacht und
mitgelacht drüber, so in der Hoffnung, so,
hoffentlich fangen wir mit dem eigentlichen Meeting erst gar nicht an,
bis die Zeit um ist.
Und es war ganz, ganz weird Atmosphäre.
Ja.
Dieser Typ fing von der ersten
Minute an, sofort an,
seine Entwicklungsleiter anzugreifen.
Jetzt weißt du aber, ob die Software nix wird.
Strunzendumm, Zitat, sie sind,
dass sie nichts geschissen kriegen.
Jetzt weißt du auch, warum die Software
nix wird.
Nicht, weil die dumm sind, die Entwicklungsleiter,
sondern wegen dem Verhältnis zwischen
den Entwicklungsleitern und dem Chef.
Wahrscheinlich, weil der Chef sich random
irgendwelche Dinge ausdenkt.
Heute so, morgen so.
Die versuchen irgendwas hinzuwursten.
Und am anderen Tag regt er sich dann drüber auf,
dass sie das gemacht haben, was er gestern gesagt hat
und nicht das von vorgestern.
Deswegen läuft das nicht.
Das liegt höchstwahrscheinlich nicht an den Entwicklungsleitern.
Noch mal ein richtiges Zitat.
Und dass er nicht verstehen würde, warum er
so viel unfähige Leute um sich versammelt hat.
Und so ging das dann immer weiter.
Und ich hab dann irgendwann gesagt, Herr,
vielleicht sollten Sie jetzt mal
aufhören, die ganze Zeit auf ihren Mitarbeitern rumzuhacken.
Vor allen Dingen in einer so abartig
abfälligen Weise von ihren Mitarbeitern,
die mit Sicherheit ihr Bestes für sie geben, zu reden.
Da sollten wir versuchen, auf ihr Problem zu
konzentrieren und versuchen, ihr Problem zu lösen
und nicht die ganze Zeit mit Dreck auf andere Menschen.
Das löst man sich bestimmt auf.
Gerade wenn du so Leute hast, die können das
überhaupt nicht ab, wenn man da was sagt.
Und da sagte der Geschäftsführer zu mir,
Herr Thielke, wie ich mit meinen Mitarbeitern rede,
das überlassen Sie bitte mir.
Den Satz kannte ich ja schon.
Den hatte ich ja schon 15 Jahre zuvor gehört.
Und just in dem Moment...
Ich glaube, das ist so ein dummer Spruch,
den du dir als Berater öfter anhören musst.
Und später
wurde meine Tochter wach.
Ich müsste euch das so vorstellen,
das ist hier, das sieht ein bisschen anders aus,
der Blickwinkel.
Und hier, was man auf der Webcam nicht sieht,
stand meine Tochter.
Sie lag in so einer Babywippe.
Sie ist erst sieben Monate, ne gar nicht, acht Monate heute.
Acht Monate alt.
Und ich hab sie dann angeguckt,
hab gelächelt und gesagt, guten Morgen.
Und sofort wurde dieser Geschäftsführer
fuchsdorfes wild und so,
der Thielke, wer ist das?
Was hat der für Probleme, Mann?
The fuck?
Direkt Teams call, close.
Das ist das Gute.
Das ist das Gute, wenn man sowas
remote führt.
Da bist du direkt weg.
Ja, okay, mach deinen Scheiß alleine, Ceo.
Dann hab ich die Kamera gedreht,
dass man meine Tochter sehen konnte.
Die hat dann in die Kamera geguckt und auch gelacht,
weil sie die Leute auf dem Bildschirm gesehen hat.
Und hab gesagt, das ist meine Tochter Lisa,
die macht heute Morgen hier das Protokoll.
Und dann fing er an, richtig wütend zu werden.
Und sagte sofort, der Thielke,
ich erwarte jetzt sofort von Ihnen, dass Sie Ihr Kind runterbringen
zu Ihrer Frau, wo das Kind hingehört.
Und wenn Sie für mich arbeiten, erwarte ich,
dass Sie konzentriert sind, fokussiert sind.
Ja, das sind so Leute, die bringen dann auch
den Spruch,
jetzt verhalten Sie sich doch mal professionell.
Oder sowas in der Richtung.
Ohne eigentlich
zu realisieren,
wer hier der Unprofessionelle
ist.
Das ist so ein typischer Spruch von solchen Leuten.
Meine Güte.
Ich glaube, Freelancer,
wenn ich das immer wieder höre,
du musst dich da auch so oft mit Volldeppen
auseinandersetzen.
Das Beste geben, dass wir unser Unternehmen
wieder in den Griff kriegen.
Ja, die beste Variante, um das Unternehmen
wieder in den Griff zu kriegen, wäre wahrscheinlich,
er lässt das irgendjemand anderes machen.
Als allererstes, meine Frau ist arbeiten.
Heute ist Donnerstag, heute ist unser Papatag.
Das heißt, vormittags arbeite ich,
da habe ich Meetings, also meistens solche
Kurzmeetings wie das. Und nachmittags
spielen wir, laufen wir oder machen
irgendetwas anderes, weil die Mama nicht da ist.
Und zweitens,
da war er aber echt diplomatisch.
Er hätte auch sagen können,
wissen Sie was,
wie ich mit meiner Tochter
umgehe, lassen Sie das mal
meine Sorge sein und auflegen.
Selbst wenn meine Tochter hier sitzt,
gebe ich natürlich immer mein Bestes und bin
hochkonzentriert und werde alles dafür geben,
um was geht es, um nervige Chefs.
Und dann fing er noch an,
so Fuchssolzel,
dass meine Tochter ihn stören würde.
Und dass ich jetzt anfangen sollte,
das Problem zu lösen.
Und ich habe dann meine Tochter
angeguckt und gesagt,
Lisa, eigentlich haben wir doch gar keine Lust
für so böse Menschen zu arbeiten, oder?
Eigentlich wollen wir doch mit solchen Leuten
gar nichts zu tun haben, vor allen Dingen nicht mit
Leuten, denen es so ist.
Da ist er komplett explodiert.
Da ist wahrscheinlich die Webcam geplatzt
vor Wutausbruch.
Und dann hat er gesagt,
ja, das ist ja voll und asozial
mit Ihren Mitarbeitern reden, oder?
Und meine Tochter hat angefangen zu lachen.
Und ich habe dann meine Tochter
aus ihrer Schale rausgenommen
und habe sie in die Kamera gehalten
und habe mich dann vor allem verabschiedet.
Also, Leute, meine Güte.
Die anderen Leute
haben das bestimmt gefeiert, ja?
Und ja.
Die Tochter hat
kein W sozusagen.
Ich habe jede Sekunde, jede einzelne Sekunde
davon genossen.
Ich arbeite nie wieder
für Menschen, die mit ihren Mitarbeitern,
mit ihren Kollegen oder sonst irgendetwas
dermaßen respektvoll umgehen.
Die sie mobben oder sonst irgendetwas.
Ich gebe immer mein Bestes,
selbst wenn meine Tochter dabei ist.
Genauso wie ihr das macht. Genauso wie du das machst.
Jeden Tag in deinem Job
das Beste. Wir verdienen dafür natürlich
Geld. Vor allen Dingen aber verdienen wir
einen respektvollen und würdevollen
Umgang der Kollegen, der
Vorgesetzten, der Geschäftsführer.
Wenn dir das nicht widerfährt, dann sei nicht so
blöd wie mein 25-jähriges
ich damals. Geh hin und
zieh Konsequenzen, weil das
muss sich niemand gefallen lassen.
Das hat niemand verdient.
Ich wünsche dir jetzt einen schönen Tag.
Viel Spaß bei der Arbeit. Bis zum
nächsten Mal und pass auf deine Aufwärme auf.
Ja, das war doch ein gutes Video.
Ah, du hast schon echt ein paar Spasten teilweise
da unterwegs. Wahnsinn.
Ich hatte ja auch schon,
ihr kennt das aus
meinen Videos und auch
was ich hier im Stream erzähle, ich hatte auch schon
fragwürdige Vorgesetzte, ja
und auch die ein oder anderen
Probleme.
Aber das
ist nochmal ein ganz anderes Level
gewesen.
Link zu dem Video,
ich hab's jetzt, geht, ist nicht mehr
im Backbrowser.
Oder warte mal, falscher Browser hier.
So Leute, nee, das ist meins.
Ja, dann weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung.
Aber findste ja, das hieß
Lasst euch das nicht gefallen und
er hieß Tielke, David Tielke.
Äh, findste schon.
So Leute, aber
ich muss jetzt auch ins Bett. Ich hab schon
eine halbe Stunde überzogen.
Chatge, wir sehen uns, macht's gut, bis denn.
See you.